TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON CENTER
DAVE CORTES IN RESPONSE TO THE
CALL THE NINETEEN THE MURDER
SCENE TO PROTECT PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL.
SENATORS SOCIAL DISTANCING M.
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. DUE
TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE TOURISTS
MAY INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. HERE EACH SIDE WILL
BE PERMITTED EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR. TODAY'S LEAD WITNESSES
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH. OF
FOR EACH WITNESS WITH NO
RESERVING OF TIME FOR OTHER
WITNESSES. ALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME THEIR
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION ON
THE MEASURES. FOR THOSE
WITNESSES SO THERE WILL BE A
LIMIT OF TEN MINUTES FOR
SUPPORT AND TEN MINUTES FOR
OPPOSITION TOTAL. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WITH ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS HELLO. AND WE AND
WE WILL BE USING TOLD COVER
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. HE WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. I
AM GOING TO ANNOUNCE IT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR IN THE ACCESS CODE IS
SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGHT THREE
TWO. AGAIN. SEVEN THREE SIX TWO
EIGHT THREE TWO FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
CONFERENCE TOTAL COMFORT SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE OR THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
PROCESSES ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER.
THIS COULD BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME HE WILL BE
ON MUTE IT AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS A COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY. AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE- I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING THIS
IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY INDIAN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WELL EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND TO CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN
AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL PATIENT.
SOUL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. WE HAVE ELEVEN BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA- WE HAVE THREE
BILLS ON CONSENT. BUT BEFORE WE
HER PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS-
WE WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM. AND
BEFORE WE DO THAT LET ME SAY AT
THE OUTSET IT IS MY INTENTION
TODAY. TO SLIGHTLY RE ORDER THE
AGENDA BY ALLOWING THE ITEM
THAT IS LISTED ON OUR AGENDA.
LAST WHICH WOULD BE S. B. FIFTY
FIVE NINETY EIGHT SENATOR PAN
TO BE HEARD. A SECOND ON THE
AGENDA- OF IN SB THIRTY THREE
WHICH IS MY BILL TO BE HER LAST
ON THE AGENDA SO I WILL BE
SWAPPING OF POSITIONS WITH
SENATOR PAN- FOR REASONS OF THE
PRAGUE OF THE CHAIR. THAT SAID-
LET ME ASK TO OUR CONSULTANT TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
CORTEZ EIGHT ZERO. SENATOR-
CHOKE SENATOR TORONTO. SENATOR
LAYERED. SENATOR NEWMAN. WE
HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WELL LET'S GO HEAD AND CAN
MOVE ON IN HERE FROM OUR FIRST
AUTHOR- THAT WOULD BE SENATOR
SPECTER. YOU SEE THAT HE'S HERE
IN CENTER BURKE WHO WILL BE
PRESENTING ON SB SEVEN SEVENTY
NINE. WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS. I'M EXCITED TO
PRESENT SB SEVEN SEVEN NINE THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE INNOVATION
OPPORTUNITY ACT THIS BILL
SUPPORT STRUCTURE ANY EFFORTS
AT THE STATE RECOVERS AND
COVERED NINETEEN BY CHRISTIAN
WORK MODELS TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF THOSE OVER COMING WORKFORCE
BARRIERS LIKE EXITING THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. THIS BILL ADDS
MODELS INTO THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE CODE THAT MAY BE
CONSIDERED WHEN FUNDING EARN
AND LEARN PROGRAMMES. THESE
MODELS INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT
LIMITED TO IMPLEMENT SOCIAL
ENTERPRISES FOR E. EASE AND
ALCAMO USE THEM WORKER COOPS.
YES THESE ARE VALUABLE PARTNERS
IN DECREASING RECIDIVISM AND
BREAKING THE CYCLE OF
HOMELESSNESS JUST GIVE A COUPLE
EXAMPLES HOMEBOY INDUSTRIES.
ROYCE SIX HUNDRED FORMER GANG
MEMBERS OR PREVIOUS
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS IN AN
EIGHTEEN MONTH JOB TRAINING
PROGRAM. SENATE FROM PLUMBING
OPPORTUNITIES EMPLOYS ABOUT
THREE THOUSAND FORMALLY CARTS
RATED CALIFORNIANS ANNUALLY IN
TEN LOCATIONS. S. C. H. P.
LAUNCH SOLUTIONS SF. EMPLOYMENT
SOCIAL ENTERPRISES TRAINS
EMPLOYEES FORMALLY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS IN FRONT AND FRONT
DESK STAFFING JOBS. YOU 80% OF
ALL ITS EMPLOYEES ARE JUST AS
INVOLVED AS 75% ARE BLACK OR
LATIN ACTS. THE FUTURE WORK
COMMISSION SOUTH DAKOTA NEWSOME
IN TWENTY NINETEEN RECOMMENDED
IN THE FINAL REPORT TO THE
STATE EXTENDED FINANCIAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TNCS BY
TWENTY THIRTY. ANOTHER
INNOVATIVE MODEL SUPPORTED BY
THIS BILL IS ARE WORKER COOPS
THERE ARE WORKERS TO ON PART OF
THE BUSINESS AND RECEIVE WAGES
AND BENEFITS WHILE IN TRAINING.
A COUPLE NOTES WE MET AT THE
BILL TO MAKE IT MORE PERMISSIVE
INDICATING A SUBSIDIZED
EMPLOYMENT INCLUDES. BUT IS NOT
LIMITED TO. SUBSIDIZE
EMPLOYMENT AS PROVIDED THROUGH
ESCS OR WORKER COOPS. IN OUR
TENNIS MAKE THIS IS INCLUSIVE
AS FEDERAL LAW ALLOWS INCLUDING
THE PUBLIC SECTOR. I'D LIKE TO
BRIEFLY ADDRESS THE OPPOSITION
LETTER THAT WAS CIRCULATED LATE
LAST WEEK. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPOSITION'S WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH OUR OFFICE WHAT WE
DID NOT LEARN OF THEIR CONCERNS
IT'S TIME FOR THIS COMMITTEE WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION. I'D LIKE TO CLOSE
BY REITERATING THE SB SEVEN
SEVEN NINE IS NOT A MANDATE.
IT'S RECOGNITION IMPORTANT ROLE
THAT EMPLOYMENT SERVICE
ENTERPRISES WORKER COOPS CAN
PLAY IN OUR TRANSITION WORK
FORCE. THESE ARE TWENTY MEMBERS
OF OUR COMMUNITY BUT OFFICIALS
WITH STEEP BARRIERS TO WORK.
BETTER IN DIRE NEED OF SUPPORT
AND SERVICES IN MESS OF OUR
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC CRISES.
CALL BUCKLEY ASTRO VOTE BUT SB
SEVEN SEVEN NINE. I TO SUPPORT
WITH ASSIST ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE CARLA JAVITS THE CEO AND
PRESIDENT OF RAF. AND LISA
COUNTRYMEN PERROS THE CO JEWISH
VOCATIONAL SERVICES. THANK YOU
SENATOR A MISCHIEVOUS YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES LET ME JUST- CALL FOR
THAT NOT JUST FOR THIS BILL BUT
ONE MORE TIME IN CASE OTHERS
WERE NOT PRESENT AT THE TIME
EARLY WITNESSES WILL BE LIMITED
TO TWO MINUTES EACH TODAY- IN-
WITNESSES CALLING ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE WILL BE
LIMITED TO OVERALL. LIMIT OF
TEN MINUTES FOR OPPOSITION OR
TEN MINUTES FOR SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF THE GAIN ON
THE JOB TO ME PROCEED WE CAN
HEAR YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH MY
NAME IS CARLA JAVITS AND I'M
THE CEO AND PRESIDENT OF RED AT
THE- CENTER PRESS BELUM FUND.
WERE CO SPONSORED SB SEVEN
SEVEN NINE. BUT IT IS A
CALIFORNIA BASED ORGANIZATION
THAT INVESTS IN AND IS BUILDING
THE FIELD OF EMPLOYMENT SOCIAL
ENTERPRISES IN CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONALLY. THESE BUSINESSES
CARRY OUT A SPECIFIC SOCIAL
MISSION TO PROVIDE THE INCOME
TRAINING AND SUPPORT SERVICES
TO THOSE OVERCOMING. WORKFORCE
BARRIERS SUCH AS THOSE WHO'VE
EXPERIENCED INCARCERATION
HOMELESSNESS MENTAL ILLNESS OR
ADDICTION. SO THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS CAN FULLY
PARTICIPATE IN OUR ECONOMY.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN
RELATIVES PROVIDED CAPITAL ONE
ADVISORY SERVICES TO ABOUT
NINETY. EMPLOYMENT SOCIAL
ENTERPRISES IN CALIFORNIA WHICH
OF TRAINED AND EMPLOYED. OVER
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
STATEWIDE. OVER TWELVE THOUSAND
FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY ALONG. EMPLOYMENT SOCIAL
ENTERPRISES STIMULATE THE
ECONOMY WHILE PROTECTING
EQUITY. NEARLY 80% OF THE
SECTOR'S EMPLOYEES ARE JUST AS
IMPACTED. AND WELL OVER HALF A
BLACK LAB MIX. THESE BUSINESSES
HELP GOVERNMENT DOLLARS GO
FURTHER WHILE IMPROVING LIVES
AND STRENGTHENING FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES WITH INDEPENDENT
RESEARCH TO VERIFY THAT THE ON
THE JOB EXPECTANCIES BUSINESSES
PROVIDE. INCREASE JOB RETENTION
AND WAGES AND DECREASE
RECIDIVISM. SB SEVEN SEVEN NINE
WILL EXPLICITLY INCLUDE THESE
ENTERPRISES IN THE EXISTING
WORKFORCE TRAINING FRAMEWORK.
DURING THE INNOVATIVE EVIDENCE
BASED SOLUTIONS STORE STATE
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL CHALLENGES.
CAN CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS
OVERCOMING BARRIERS TO WORK. BY
ADDING IS BUSINESSES TO THE WE-
DEFINITION OF LEARNING LEARNING
PROGRAMS THIS BILL WILL HELP
LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARDS FEET. IMPLEMENT SOCIAL
ENTERPRISES AND VALUABLE
TRAINING AND EMPLOYMENT
PROVIDERS. AND ENSURE THAT OUR
ECONOMIC RECOVERY IS MORE
EQUITABLE AND FULLY INCLUSIVE.
WE URGE YOU TO VOTE HI. SB.
SEVEN SEVEN NINE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU CAN UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS A ASIDE WITNESS.
RESEARCH CURO- IF YOU THERE YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. THREE MY NAME IS
WITH CONCERN CARE ON THE OF J.
WHICH THEY OKAY SERVICE WE AT
WORK FIRST OF ALL ORDER.
HEADQUARTERED IN FRANCISCO
OPERATING THROUGHOUT THE BAY
AREA- AND POINTS. WE ARE ALSO A
CO SPONSOR OF A SEVEN SEVEN AND
VERY. OF IMPORTANT ROLE THAT
WORKER COOPER CAN PLAY
ESPECIALLY AT A TIME OF
ECONOMIC DESTRUCTION WE'RE IN
RIGHT NOW- IN OFFERING MANY
ADVANTAGES FOR WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS AND PROVIDERS. BURGER
CO OPS OFFER A NEW WAY TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO WORK BASED
LEARNING WHICH WE KNOW OF
PROVIDERS IS CRITICAL FOR ADULT
LEARNER SUCCESS. IN APPEALING
TO RECESSION OBVIOUSLY THERE
ARE FAR FEWER OPPORTUNITIES
READILY AVAILABLE IN THE MARKET
AND THERE ARE FAR FEWER
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEVERAGE EVEN
THE SUBSIDIZED EMPLOYMENT
DOLLARS THE EXIT. WORKER COOPS
CREATE ADDITIONAL MECHANISMS
THAT ALLOW US TO TRULY CREATE
NEW EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR JOB SEEKERS- I'LL GIVE YOU
AN EXAMPLE WE HAVE LAUNCHED A
PROGRAM IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
TURNING BEACON LAB WORKER. COOP
WE PARTNER VERY CLOSELY WITH.
RICK TRYING THROUGH THIS PRO.
WE ARE ABLE TO BUILD ON THE
CLASSROOM BASED TRAINING OR
PROVIDING IN QUICKBOOKS AND
BOOKKEEPING AND WE'RE POLICING
WORKERS IN POSITION WITH SMALL
BUSINESSES BUT BOTH MATT. WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN IN A POSITION TO
HIRE WORKERS WE ARE SUBSIDIZING
THE COST OF THAT WORK THROUGH
THE WORKER COOPER- AND- BY
CREATING ACCESS TO. OUR TROOP
ON RAMP INTO CAREERS WHICH
COULD INCLUDE CONTINUED WORK
THROUGH THE COOP WELL WORKERS
HAVE PROTECTIONS AND BENEFITS.
AND SOME OF OUR PROGRAMS HAVE
DONE IT COULD MEAN INVESTMENT
INTO A POSITION AT THE
CORPORATION SO. WHENEVER FIRST
GRADUATE AND UP GETTING UP A
ROLL THAT INTO IT OR IT COULD
ULTIMATELY MEAN- BECOMING AN
ENTREPRENEUR AND LAUNCHING
THEIR OWN BUSINESS. THE GREAT
THING ABOUT WORKERS COBB IS
THAT THEY DO OFFER THAT
EXPANDED ACCESS TO WORK BASED
LEARNING WHILE ALSO OFFERING
JOB QUALITY BENEFITS THAT
INCLUDE HEALTH BENEFITS. AND
THEN HOLD ON ALSO WORKABLE IT
AS WORKERS ARE CO OWNERS- AND
THEREFORE A VARIETY OF NEW
TRANSITION. INTO HIGH QUALITY
EMPLOYMENT. A STRONG SUPPORTS.
SEVEN SEVEN NINE AS A TO- TO
SUPPORT THE MODERN. OF OUR WORK
LISTA. THANK YOU. THANK FOR
YOUR TO. OF WILL CONTINUE TO
FOR SUPPORT WITNESSES NOW
STARTING WITH ANY WHO ARE HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN THE TWENTY ONE
ROOM WISHING. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF A C. NONE WILL LOOK
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY YOUR ROOM.
SEEN NONE. WE WILL COME BACK
NOW TO OUR MODERATOR AND WILL
MOVE ON TO SUPPORT WITH
WITNESSES WILLING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR I UNDERSTAND YOUR
NAME IS DAVID AT SOME EXCELLENT
NAME- IF YOU PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SEVEN
NINE. WE CAN BEGIN. LA GERMAN
IF YOU ARE A SUPPORT OF IT SOON
SEVEN NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. YOU WILL
HEAR A TONE INDICATING PLACING
QUEUE NUMBER WILL PROVIDE YOU A
NUMBER THAT WILL THEN ANNOUNCE
YOU BY THAT NUMBER. ONCE
INSURANCE SUPPORT THE BEST B.
SEVEN SEVEN NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AND I WILL FIRST GO
TO NUMBER TWO TWENTY TWO TWO
TWO TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
K. MEMBERS JENNIFER WELL ON
BEHALF OF THE COMBO CALIFORNIA
GOODWILL INDUSTRIES PRINT THE
PART. THE NEXT TO MOVE TO
NUMBER TWO FORTY TWO FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS AND- YOU CAN ADD
PERSONAL KID OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTRE FROM PLAIN
OPPORTUNITIES AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER ONE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SANDERS ZACHARY
WARMER FOR THE DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S
CENTER AT LOS ANGELES STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT WILL
BE NUMBER TWO THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YET THE FINAL OPEN
WITH GOOD WELL THOUGHT IN
CALIFORNIA IN LOS ANGELES AND
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE AND ALSO
REPRESENTING FOURTEEN GOOD
WORLD ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. SIX OF THE NUMBER TWO
OH THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
WRITING STEVEN WHITTAKER I'M
WITHOUT DEMANDING THAT. THEY
PROVIDE- WE ARE WHAT WE CALL
BASED IN CALIFORNIA. WHAT COULD
CALLING WHAT WE ACTUALLY
COLLABORATED TAKING AT THE
PROGRAM THAT YOU CAN DESCRIBE-
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND THEY
PROVIDE INNOVATIVE WAY FOR
CALIFORNIANS ACCESS. AREAS AS
WELL AS DENTAL SACRISTAN AND
**** COME TO ME- WE GOT TO MEET
THE MOMENT I MEAN THE FACT THAT
THE ECONOMY IS BECOMING MORE
MORE DYNAMIC SO- I SUPPOSE BUT.
OUR NEXT MOVIE NUMBER TWO
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. KAREN
MEMBERS WOULD BE PHANTASM
BEHALF OF THAT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT ONE
O'CLOCK APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORITY TO GRANT SMALL DROPS
IN CONCERNS THAT WOULD HAVE
INADVERTENTLY ARE STOPPED
MIRRORING FEDERAL LAW. THAT THE
BANDAGE OF PUBLIC SECTOR
EMPLOYERS THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO NUMBER TWO NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT THE TRISH STARKEY WHAT
GOOD WELL OF SILICON VALLEY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOUNG.
THE NEXT YEAR THE NUMBER TWO
SIXTEEN TO SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
KERRY DOWN DECKER A PROUD BOARD
MEMBER AT JEWISH VOCATIONAL
SERVICES- IN STRONG SUPPORT SB
SEVEN SEVEN NINE AND
RESPECTFULLY PERJURE BY VOTE.
ONE FAMILY ENJOYMENT YOUR IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SEVEN NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
SUPPORT PLEASE CONTINUE MR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WE WILL MOVE NOW TO
THE SAME PROCESS BUT WITH THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES A- CORRECT.
I DON'T SEE NONE- WE WILL MOVE
ON TO THE COMMITTEE ROOMS OR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN SEVEN
NINE. C. NONE I WALKED TO THE
OVERFLOW ROOM ROOM TWO ZERO
FOUR ZERO. A SEEN NONE WELCOME
BACK TO THE MODERATOR FOR
MODERATE REVIEW WITH A PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVENTY NINE-
WE CAN BEGIN PLEASE INDICATE TO
US THE TOTAL NUMBER. PERSONS
WAITING TO FIND OPPOSITION. JIM
IF YOU'RE NOW IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN SEVEN NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF SB.
SEVEN SEVEN NINE. AT THIS TIME
WE ONLY HAVE ONE IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
ABSOLUTELY ARE- WILL FIRST GO
TO LINE TWO THIRTY TWO. LINE
TWO THIRTY TWO YOUR OPEN. A
LINE TO THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN
MEMBERS OF THAT WITH THE
PANCAKE OF THE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION. ALLERGIES AGAIN TO
ABOUT THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE PARLAYED OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED LETTER AT THE
CENTER MENTION WE SPOKE WITH
BOTH HE AND WITH THIS KIND OF
OPPOSITION RESEARCH ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW THIS BILL
PROPOSES DATA TYPE OF TRAINING
TO CODE THAT IS ALREADY
ALLOWABLE OTHER UNDER OTHER
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW. THAT IS
ALREADY A BEST PRACTICE THAT IS
FREQUENTLY USED BY LOCAL
WORKFORCE BOARDS IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH EMPLOYMENT SOCIAL
ENTERPRISES WE ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE OPERATORS ARE
CONCERNED AND WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO WORK WITH US
MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR MURRAY OF SECOND CLUED
WITNESS WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. ARE ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. YOU MISTER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE WELCOME BACK TO. THE
COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION- SAN
EARLIER S. I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT- I'M FAMILIAR WITH SOME OF
THE SUPPORTERS AND PEOPLE THAT
BENEFIT FROM THIS WHETHER IT'S
RANCHO CIELO IN MONTEREY COUNTY
OR THE LOCAL CONSERVATION
COURSE AND THEY REALLY DEAL. OF
WHO WITH. THE PEOPLE WITH THAT
ARE DISADVANTAGED WITH A
DISPROPORTIONATE. IMPACT ON
THEM AND SO I THINK THIS
REACHES. ARE A GOOD GROUP OF
PEOPLE I KNOW IT'S NOT A
MANDATE I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY
HOW YOU CAN BE ABLE TO MOVE THE
BILL. I APPRECIATE. THAT YOU'RE
WILLING TO WORK WITH A PERSON
THAT HAS CONCERNED TO THE GROUP
THAT HAS CONCERNS AND WHEN
THERE'S AN APPROPRIATE TIME I
WILL MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR A SENATOR ALSO SO YOU
LEANING IN. YES THANK YOU
SENATOR- BACKGROUND I DO INTEND
TO SUPPORT- YOUR BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I DO HAVE A QUESTION.
UNLESS IT REALLY GETS TOO LONG-
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE WORK
FORCE ASSOCIATION IS THAT MORE
OF A TECHNICAL ISSUE OR IS IT A
SUBSTANTIVE ISSUE AND- IF YOU
COULD RESPOND TO IT. SURE YEAH
AS. MENTIONED WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THEM.
DID YOU KNOW THAT THEIR- I
THINK THE CONCERN IS THAT THIS
IS PERMISSIBLE. AND IMPORTANT
POINT THIS BILL IS JUST TO SAY
THAT- THAT WE WANT TO SUPPORT
THIS TYPE OF PROGRAM. FURTHER
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA SPENT ONE
POINT 5% OF THESE FEDERAL FUNDS
ON TRANSITIONAL PLUMMET. D. C.
W. D. B. WHICH IS A MEMBER OF
FOR SEVEN YEARS A RECENT
INCREASE ALLOWABLE PERCENTAGE
OF FEDERAL WORK FORCE DOLLARS.
THAT COULD BE SPENT ON
TRANSITION PLANNING FROM 10% TO
THIRTY PERCENT. SO WE HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO AND THAT'S
REALLY THE POINT OF THIS BILL
IS TO ENCOURAGE. TO DO MORE
HERE AGAIN NOT A MANDATE SO WE
FEEL THAT WE CAN WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION. OKAY THANK YOU.
VERY THE DISCUSSION NON MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE- IF NOT SOONER
BURKE RICHARD CLOSE. SHORT HE
ACTUALLY LEARNING ABOUT READ F.
IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN WAS
SOMETHING THAT THAT WAS THE
EVENT THAT WAS PEOPLE FOR ME
ENCOURAGING MIGHT INTERESTED.
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND HAVING
SERVED ON THE C. TO B. B. I DO
BELIEVE DO YOU BELIEVE THESE
ARE IMPORTANT OR ACTIONS FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GOING
FORWARD. I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS AND THE INTEREST AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
PATTERSON ROAD I MOVED THE
BILL. THE BILL'S BEEN MOVE-
LESSER. FOR WILL CALL THE
POLICE. THE MOTION IS TO PAY AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST A MAN AND RE
REFER TO COMMIT ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR CORTEZ
EIGHT BY. SENATOR CORTEZ III
SENATOR OCHO BOKE HI. AND- OCHO
BOGUE HI SENATOR TORONTO.
SENATOR ROSS- I SENATOR LAYERED
HI SENATOR LAYERED BY SENATOR
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT SENATOR NEWMAN
HI. OF THAT MOTION HAS FIVE
VOTES. THANK YOU BILLS OUT
THANK YOU SENATOR. WELL WELCOME
SENATOR PENN YOU MAY PRESENT
YOUR SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT AND
BEFORE YOU START SPEAKING LET
ME CLARIFY FOR LATE ARRIVALS
THAT CENTER PAN AND I SWITCHED
POSITIONS ON THE PRINTED AGENDA
SO HE IS GOING FORWARD NOW AND
I WILL BE GOING FORWARD
ESSENTIALLY LAST ON THE AGENDA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE SENATE
CORTESE FOR HELPING ACCOMMODATE
MY FAMILY. SCHEDULES WELL- SB
FIVE NINETY EIGHT WOULD PLACE
AN UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE
CHARGES UNDER THE JURISDICTION
OF THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONS BOARD OUR PURPOSE FOR
TO SACRAMENTO REGIONAL TRANSIT
WHICH OPERATES IN MY DISTRICT.
CURRENTLY MOST PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
DO FALL UNDER PURPOSE
JURISDICTION. FOR RESOLUTION
PLAYER EMPLOYEE CONFLICTS
HOWEVER MOST TRANSIT DISTRICTS
HOW REMAIN UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE STATE COURT
SYSTEM DUE TO HISTORICAL
PRECEDENT. SO TO RESOLVE A
CONFLICT BETWEEN SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL TRANSIT ONE SIMPLY
ORGANIZATIONS A WRIT MUST BE
FILED IN SUPERIOR COURT BUT ONE
OF THE INVOLVED PARTIES. THIS
EXISTING PROCESS IS TIME
CONSUMING EXPENSIVE MAY
ACTUALLY PLACE AN UNFAIR
PRACTICE CHARGE WITH THE JUDGE
WITH LITTLE OR NO EXPERIENCE
WITH EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS. IN COMPARISON THE
PURPLE CONFLICT RESOLUTION
PROCESS TO STREAMLINE.
STREAMLINED LESS EXPENSIVE FOR
EMPLOYER ORGANIZATIONS A
TAXPAYERS IN PARTICULAR TO
CONFLICT RESOLUTION WITHIN
PUBLIC SECTORS. SB FIVE NINETY
EIGHT IS SUPPORTED BY
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL TRANSIT
APPS ME AND THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS. BUT THE S. THREE AYE
VOTE I DO HAVE WITNESSES FROM-
DAVID PHILLIPS IN BEHALF OF
APPS ME AND TEMPERAMENT TO BE
HALF THE OPERATING ENGINEERS
THANK YOU. WHO TO THANK YOU
SENATE-ROOM WELCOME. TO READ
SUPPORT WITNESS TO PROCEED.
WITH THIS MISTER PHILLIPS.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU THE POLICE. I
THANK YOU UP COULD AFTER MR
MEMBER. THANK YOU FOR THE UP.
TO SPEAK OF THE OF A- S. B.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT MY NAME AGAIN
IS DAVID PHILLIPS. I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF ASK THE LOCAL ONE
FORTY SIX AND ALSO A NINETEEN
YEAR EMPLOYEE OF THE FACT
MENTAL REGIONAL TRANSIT
DISTRICT. UNDER OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM OF EMPLOYEE EMPLOYER
RELATIONS THAT FALLS UNDER THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE. NOT THE
MYERS MILLIONS BROWN ACTON
PURPOSE WHICH PROVIDES
JURISDICTION FOR MOST PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION. UNDER
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM IF THERE IS
AN ALLEGATION OF EUROPEAN
VIOLATIONS WERE REQUIRED TO
FILE WRITTEN THE STATE SUPERIOR
COURT. THIS PROCESS CAN TAKE
YEARS TO GET A JUDGMENT AND
THIS COULD BE FROM A JUDGE THAT
ME OR MAY NOT HAVE EXPERIENCE
IN LABOR LAW. THIS IS ALSO A
COSTLY PROCESS WHERE THE
TAXPAYERS ARE THE ONES THAT
ULTIMATELY PICK UP THE TAB.
THIS BILL CHANGES THAT BY
POLICE AFFECT MY REGIONAL TRIP
THE WORKERS UNDER PREPARE
RESTRICTION. THIS IS A COST
EFFECTIVE AND TIMELY WAY THE
SOLVING POORLY EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS. IT ENSURES THAT BOTH
THE EMPLOYER. AND EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS BARGAIN IN GOOD
FAITH. IT LIMITS INTERFERENCE
WITH EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION
RIGHT. AT THE SAME TIME IT
PROTECTS THE EMPLOYEES FROM
BEING DISCRIMINATED AGAINST.
FOR LACK OF FAIR REPRESENTATION
BY THE EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT THEY BELONG TO. THIS WILL
CREATE UNIFORMITY WITHIN THE
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS FOR THE
TRANSIT EMPLOYEES ARE PART OF A
LARGER GROUP OF PUBLIC WORKERS.
THESE PAST FEW YEARS WE SAW
OTHER TRANSIT AGENCIES BEGIN
THIS PROCESS. AND WITH YOUR
SUPPORT WE HOPE TO JOIN WITH
WORKERS FROM LA METRO. ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSIT AND THE BAY AREA
RAPID TRANSIT. THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MR
PHILLIPS MISTER. TO THROUGH
THERE YOU CAN PROCEED. YEAH THE
SHIPMENT TO CHAIRMAN- TIM CRAB
INTERNATION OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS. I THINK YOU'VE HEARD
MOST OF THE SECOND POINT VOCAL
REAL QUICK- THIS BILL IF YOU
HER GIVE OUR MEMBERS A REGIONAL
TRANSIT CIVIL RIGHTS GIVEN
OTHER LOCAL GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES UNDER THE MYERS
BILLY'S BROWN DECK- THIS BILL
WOULD RESULT IN FAIR LABOR
PRACTICES THAT SACK R. T- I
THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT POINT
HERE IS ENDORSED BOTH BY LABOR
AND MANAGEMENT- THIS PROPOSAL
SAVE RESOURCES AND TIME AND
THAT CONSISTENCY. AND
PREDICTABILITY LABOR RELATIONS
THAT SACRAMENTO REGIONAL
TRANSIT DISTRICT I THANK YOU
AND WE ARE READY TO ACCEPT
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE THEM.
THANK YOU WHO YOU ARE FIRST CAN
MOVE TO ADDITIONAL- WITNESSES
AT THIS POINT PLEASE STAND BY-
CASE OR ANY QUESTIONS- FIRST
WILL BUT TURN TO THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. YES WITH A- POLICE A STEP
FORWARD AND IDENTIFY YOURSELF
AND YOU'LL HAVE- TWO MINUTES
THIS WEEK- ARCHER RECORD TV IT
SENATORS TERRY BRENNAN ON
BEHALF VETS YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA. SPECIFICALLY LOCAL
FIVE TWO ONE S. C. R. U. THIS
BILL IS MODELED ON. A S. B. AB
TWO EIGHTY OF LAST YEAR FOR THE
PARTY POLICE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR FOR
POSSIBLE INCLUSION OF OTHER.
TRANSIT AGENCIES ARE CURRENTLY
NEGOTIATING THIS IS GOOD PUBLIC
PRACTICE WILL DRIVE OUT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER- WITNESSES IN. THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WISH TO SPEAK ON
THE BILL. A SEEN SEEN NONE WILL
MOVE TO- STILL ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. A SINGLE PERSON'S
THEY'RE WISHING TO SPEAK WILL
GO TO OUR MODERATOR DAVID- CAN
YOU PLEASE CERTAIN QUEUE UP.
ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME BY TOLD
CORPORATE SERVICES INC PLEASE
LET US KNOW HOW MANY WITNESSES
YOU HAVE TO DO. ANALYZE YOUR
CURRENT SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB. FIVE NINE EIGHT. AT THIS
TIME WE ONLY HAVE ONE IN THE
QUEUE. PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU.
AND WE WILL START WITH- LINE TO
FORTY FOUR TO FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. YES THANK YOU- MY
NAME'S HUNTER STERN I'M WITH
IBEW LOCAL TWELVE FORTY FIVE- I
DO HAVE A TWELVE FORTY FIVE IS
ALSO HAVE OVER TWO HUNDRED
MEMBERS WORKING FOR PSYCHOLOGY
AND WE ARE STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF
THIS. BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR DO YOU
HAVE ANYONE ELSE CUED UP TO
SPEAK UP IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
SOMEONE TENANTS ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE NINE EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE MR. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR- MOVE FORWARD THROUGH
THE SAME PROCESS WITH THE
OPPOSITION SIDE- I SEEM TO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS IDENTIFIED.
UP BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM
IS THERE ANYONE HERE. IN THIS
ROOM WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. C. NONE
A LOOK TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY ARE
THERE ARE NO OTHER WITNESSES-
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY. ON THIS
BILL BURKE THE MODERATOR FOR
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. THIS
MOTOR CAN YOU PLEASE THE- QUEUE
UP ANY WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. I AM PLEASE LET US KNOW.
HOW MANY PERSONS WISH TO SPEAK.
NOW IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE NINE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION. AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. FIVE NINE
EIGHT. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NOBODY IN THE QUEUE. PLEASE
CONTINUE MR. THANK YOU DAVID
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND CENTER LEARN. I
HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR
NOTES. AND IT'S I EXPLORED
DOING THIS WITH THE SANTA CRUZ
TRANSIT DISTRICT THIS YEAR IN A
BOARD I SERVED ON FOR NINE
YEARS ONCE. AND THEY WENT FROM
ZERO TO SIXTY IN OPPOSITION
WITHIN THE FIRST FEW HOURS ARE
THEY JUST HATED IT THEY JUST
WERE. ABSOLUTELY NOT GONNA
STAND FOR HOW IS MANAGEMENT
WORKING WITH YOU SO WELL
WONDERS HOW DID YOU GET TO A
POINT THAT THE BOTH SIDES ARE
BACK AT THIS BECAUSE- IT TOOK.
EVAN LOW THREE TIMES TO DO THE
BARK BILL BEFORE IT FINALLY.
GOT THERE AND SOMEHOW. YOU'VE
GOTTEN TO THE PLACE THAT NOBODY
ELSE GOT TO COULD YOU GIVE A
TIP TO THE REST OF US. I'M JUST
VERY PROUD OF THE PEOPLE-SACRAMENTO AND WE TRY TO WORK
TO SOLVE PROBLEMS HEY YOU'RE
TURNED OUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
RUN AGAIN YOU DON'T HAVE TO SAY
THAT. WE DON'T IF THE I THINK
IT WAS MENTIONED BUT IT'S TRUE.
THERE'S OTHER OPPORTUNITIES-
FOR OTHER PEOPLE COME TO
AGREEMENT CERTAINLY ONE HELP
THEM AS WELL. THANK YOU. OKAY
WELL IT. ARE MY TIP OFF TO THE
SIDE GET THE CONTACTS YOU HAVE.
AT YOUR DISTRICT AND HAVE THEM
CALL THE GENERAL MANAGER IN
SANTA CRUZ- WHAT THEM KNOW THAT
THIS ISN'T THE END OF THE
WORLD. THANK YOU
CONGRATULATIONS ON THIS I LOOK
FORWARD TO VOTING FOR. THANK
YOU. BECAUSE LIKE A GOOD IDEA
AS LONG AS YOU SEE SIX FEET
APART FROM. ANYONE WAS TO UTICA.
FOR THE FOR DISCUSS BILL YES
MEMBERS. I HAD A- AND IT'S
REGARDS TO THE SEAS WERE. READ
IT. INTO THE ABILITY FOR THIS
AGENCY TO BE ABLE TO- ADDRESS
THESE ADDITIONAL CASES IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING AND BEING THAT
I'M VISITING ON SEVERAL
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS I'M A
FRESHMAN SENATOR I'M LEARNING
ABOUT ALL THESE AGENCIES AND
THE BACKLOG THAT MOST OF THESE
AGENCIES HAVE AND THEIR ABILITY
TO PROCESS- CASES I AM UNDER
THE IMPRESSION AND I AM. SORRY
ABOUT SEVENTY OTHERS INJURED
CURRENCY- IS IT HAS THERE BEEN
ANY CONCERN WITH THEIR ABILITY
TO PERFORM- AB OR PRICES THESE
THESE CASES BECAUSE IT'S- AND I
DON'T HAVE THAT KIND OF ON THE
NUMBERS IN FRONT OF ME BUT- THE
NUMBER OF BACKLOG CASES THAT
THEY HAVE AN ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THAT THEY RECEIVED IN THE PAST
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO TRUST
THAT WE ARE THE RIGHT NOW AND-
WITH RESPECT TO THAT. SO WELL
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION IS
SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY IS A
FORMER CHAIR OF. THIS COMMITTEE
AS WELL AS THE FORMER CHAIR OF
THE PUBLIC PAYMENT- COMMITTEE
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE AS WELL.
THERE HAS ONLY WE'VE DEALT WITH
SOME BACKLOGS OVER AT- PER AND-
WE BUT I SHOULD BE WORKING TO
ADDRESS THOSE- BUT I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT THE ALTERNATIVE
WHICH IS THE COURTS SYSTEMS
EVEN MORE BACKED UP. AND EFFECT
EVEN MORE COSTLY SO- CERTAINLY-
YOU KNOW WE CAN TRY TO BETTER
IMPROVE- IN TERMS OF SUPPORT
FUNDING FOR PURPOSE TO MOVE
THINGS MORE QUICKLY THROUGH
PURPOSE. BUT PURPOSE CERTAINLY
A MUCH SUPERIOR WAY OF
RESOLVING THESE DISPUTES THEN
GOING TO THE COURTS AND THAT
THAT'S WHY BOTH MANAGEMENT AND
LABOR BOTH- AT IN SAC ARE. AND
THE LEBANESE REPRESENT TO
PLEASE BOTH ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. OKAY SO THEIR ARMS
SO THEY THEY DON'T MIND TAKING
ON THESE ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES WITH THEIR
BACK I MEAN WHERE ARE THEY
RIGHT NOW AS FAR AS THE BACKLOG
ARE STILL AT LEAST A PRETTY
BACK. BUT AGAIN I WOULD POINT
OUT THAT THE- GOING TO THE
COURT SYSTEM IS MUCH MORE
COSTLY AND LESS TIMELY.
ABSOLUTE GREEN FOR OF SYSTEM
SO- SO WELL I DO RECOGNIZE
THAT- THERE HAVE BEEN BACK UPS
AT PER BUT THEY'RE NOWHERE NEAR
WHAT. THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH.
WITH THE COURT SYSTEM AS WELL
AS AS I POINTED OUT EARLIER IN
MY TESTIMONY. PURPOSE DESIGNED
TO HANDLE THESE DISPUTES THE
JUDGES. ARE FAMILIAR WITH THE
LABOR LAW IF YOU GO TO THE
COURT SYSTEM- YOU MADE END UP
WITH THAT. NOW THE JUDGE MAY
NOT HAVE THAT FAMILIARITY AND
SO IT'S A MORAL. NO PROLONGED-
BUT CONSTRUCTIVE PROCESS
SOMETIMES AT AND GOING TO THE
PUB SYSTEM SO THAT'S WHY BOTH
MANAGEMENT AND LABOR- WANT TO.
DO IS. USE THE PURPOSE SYSTEM
IS THE WAY TO RESOLVE THEIR
DISPUTES AND THAT'S IMPRESSIVE
I ACTUALLY COMMEND AGREE WITH
SENATOR LEARNED ON THAT
ENDEAVOR I WAS JUST KIND OF
CURIOUS AS TO THE STATUS AS THE
BACKLOG- PORTION OF. OF THE OF
THE AGENCY IN FOR THEY WERE AS
FAR AS RESOLVING THAT ISSUE. I
WOULD HAVE TO SINCE IT'S BEEN
AWHILE SINCE I'VE CHAIRED THE
SENATE COMMITTEE I'D HAVE TO
DEFER TO STAFF OR OTHER PEOPLE
AS TO WHAT THE EXACT STATUS OF
THE- PROBATE. COURT SYSTEM IS
AT THIS POINT TIME. IT IS TO-
SO MAKING IT BUT I DON'T THINK
WE HAVE ANYONE PRESENT TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION. BUT WE DO
NOT. HE TURNED BACK TO THE ONE
OF THE LEAD WITNESSES IF INDEED
THEY KNOW THE ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION BUT ABSENT THAT- HI.
YES THEY DO IN FOR SOCIAL CARE
TERRY BURN ABOUT HALF OF THIS
YEAR YOU CALIFORNIA. I WOULD
SAY YOU'RE RIGHT HISTORICALLY
THE PER BOARD WAS BACKLOGGED IT
WAS UNDERFUNDED FOR YEARS
UNDERSTAFFED. IS MATTER OF FACT
IT NEVER HAD A FULL CONTINGENT
OF PER BOARD MEMBERS- IT FOR
YEARS THERE WERE ONLY THREE AND
SOMETIMES FOUR MEMBERS. THAT
HAS BEEN RESOLVED IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS IN THIS LEGISLATURE
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS.
THEY'RE FULLY FUNDED FULLY
STAFFED THE BACKLOG IS DIMINISH
DRAMATICALLY- THOSE CASES THAT
EXIST NOW THAT I'M AWARE OF
THAT BEEN ON THE BOOKS FOR MORE
THAN A YEAR. OUR COMPLEX CASES
NOT. A TICKET TO A PROBLEM WITH
COMPLEXITY AND NOT STAFFING AND
NOT BE A- NUMBER OF CASES
COMING FORWARD. THE OTHER THING
TO REMEMBER IS WHEN WE DID AB
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY LAST YEAR.
THE BUDGET AMOUNT WHAT IS THE
COST IN THE- PROBATE-
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. WITH
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND THAT WAS JUST TO DRAFT THE
REGULATIONS THEY HAD PLENTY OF
STAFF AND TIME. TO ACCOMMODATE
ONE OF THE LARGEST AGENCIES IN
THE STATE. SO I CAN'T IMAGINE
THAT THIS IS GOING TO CREATE A
FURTHER BACKLOG OR ANYMORE-
MUCH MORE WORK FOR A VERY
EXPERTISE AGENCY AT THIS POINT.
OKAY THEN I DID FIND HERE THE.
INFORMATION I WAS SIGNED SAID-
THEY IN OUR TO ADDRESS THE
BACKLOG WAS ONE FOR FIVE
MILLION- AS FAR AS THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND- BUDGET.
AND THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED ONE
POINT TWO MILLION I'M GOING AS
PART OF THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND TWENTY BUDGET TO
CONTINUE REDUCING THIS BACKLOG
I WAS JUST KIND OF CURIOUS AS
TO WHAT THE STATUS WAS ON ON
THAT ENDEAVOR- OKAY SO
BASICALLY WHAT I'M
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT RIGHT NOW
YOU DON'T FOR SEE AN ISSUE WITH
THEM CARRYING ON INTERNATIONAL
CASES THEY HAVE TO STOP AND
THEY HAVE THE FUNDING THE
ONGOING FUNDING THAT THEY WILL
NEED TO BE ABLE TO BE EFFICIENT
THAT'S INTO YOU THINK ABOUT THE
PER BOARD ACTUALLY HANDLES
LABOR DISPUTES ACROSS PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES IS THAT THE MAIN
EXCEPTION HAS BEEN TRANSIT
AUTHORITIES AND GIVEN THE SIZE
OF SAC RT I DON'T THINK THAT.
WE'RE GONNA BE ADDING
SIGNIFICANTLY TO THE WORKLOAD
OF THE PER BOARD THAT THEY ARE
READY- DEAL WITH IN TERMS OF
ALL THE DIFFERENT PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE- UNITS A DAY OF UNIONS
THAT THEY DEAL WITH. OKAY WELL
I HAVE NO PROBLEM SUPPORTING IT
IF I UNDERSTAND THAT THE AGENCY
IS ABLE TO HANDLE THE
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD WITHOUT
CARRYING IT. YOU KNOW IN
PUTTING IT BACK INTO A HUGE
BACKLOG WHERE- AS I'VE LEARNED
THROUGH OTHER AGENCIES IN OUR
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS. IT
JUST BECOMES- YOU KNOW JUST.
BUT SIX MONTHS INTO BEING ABLE
TO PROCESS SO THAT'S WHAT I WAS
LOOKING AT. THANK YOU TO. GET
ANYTHING ELSE FROM A MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THE CENTER PANEL
QUESTION I HAVE IS WITH REGARD
TO AMENDMENTS- BUT- YOU TAKE ME
AMENDMENTS- ON THIS ITEM. OF NO
NO MEMBERS ON THE SIDE OF I
DON'T BELIEVE ANY AT THE MOMENT
SO COULD. THE REQUESTED FROM
THE COMMITTEE. OKAY THANK YOU
FOR CLARIFYING THAT'S MY
MISTAKE- WITH THAT SENATE PANEL
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE CLOTHES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ONE EITHER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE CAN
ATTAIN A MOTION. WITH MOVES ON
THE BILL'S MOVE BY SENATOR
LAYERED- CALL FOR ROLL CALL
VOTE PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
SENATOR CORTEZ ON SENATOR
CORTEZ THE AYE SENATOR OR CHOKE.
SENATOR OCHO POGUE HI SENATOR
DORADO SENATOR ALSO I CENTER
LAYERED HI SENATOR LAYERED I
SENATOR NEWMAN SENATOR NEWMAN
AYE THE MOTION HAS FIVE THAT'S
THANK YOU THE BILLS UP THANK
YOU. YOUR BILL BEFORE WE MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT ITEM ON THE
AGENDA WHICH IN ORDER WOULD BE
S. B. TWO SEVENTY CENTER DRAWS-
PLEASE PAUSE FOR A MOMENT-
FINTECH OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WHICH IS THREE BILLS SERVICE
LISTED ON THE PRINTER GENDER SB
FIVE OH FIVE SB. FIVE FORTY
NINE THEN S. B. SEVENTY SIX.
MISTER CHAIR I MOVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THANK YOU SENATOR
CENTER WHERE MOVES CONSENT
CALENDAR ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE.
MEMBERS ARE VOTING ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SENATOR
CORTESE BY EDITOR CORTEZ THE
AYE SENATOR- CHOKE. SENATOR A
CHOKE HI SENATOR ALSO. SENATOR
DORADO AYE SENATOR LAYERED HI
SENATOR LAYERED I SENATOR
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT SENATOR NEWMAN
HI THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS FIVE
ZERO. THANK YOU THE SERVER TWO
ZERO FIVE SENATORS TO RUSSELL-
WORLD WELCOME TO PRESENT FROM
THE DIESS UNDER CODE PROTOCOL
ON THE S. B. TWO SEVENTY OKAY.
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND UP MEMBERS
SB TWO SEVENTY EIGHT WILL
ENSURE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS RECEIVE ACCURATE
AND TIMELY BARGAINING UNIT
INFORMATION WHICH THEY ARE
ALREADY ENTITLED TO BY LAW. SO
THAT THEY MAY FULFILL THEIR
LEGAL REPRESENTATIONAL DUTIES
AND ALSO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THEIR BARGAINING UNIT AS A
WHOLE EVEN THOUGH MANY PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS TO FOLLOW THE LAW
UNFORTUNATELY. MANY EMPLOYERS
FAIL TO MEET THEIR LEGAL
OBLIGATIONS TO BOTH THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND THE PUBLIC- IN
THE EDUCATION SECTOR ALONE OUT
OF SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY SIX
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES. TWO
HUNDRED FORTY TWO HAVE NOT
SUBMITTED THE MONTHLY NEW HIRE
LIST AS REQUIRED BY LAW SINCE
THE START OF THE CALENDAR YEAR.
WITH NO CONSEQUENCES SB TWO
SEVENTY ESTABLISHES
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES WITH
PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
EMPLOYER TO CURE THE PROBLEM
RESPOND AND AVOID ANY
INVOLVEMENT FROM PER. THIS
MEASURE CREATES NO NEW RETRACT
REQUIREMENTS FOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS IT'S SIMPLY
INCENTIVIZE COMPLIANCE WITH
EXISTING LAW AND PROVIDES
FLEXIBILITY TO EMPLOYERS SO
THAT THEY MAY MEET THEIR
CURRENT LEGAL OBLIGATIONS. AS
WE TO SEVENTY GIVES PER OF THE
FULL AND COMPLETE AUTHORITY TO
DETERMINE WHAT SOLUTIONS WILL
WITH THE LAW AND UNDERSTAND THE
OBLIGATIONS THAT PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS ARE FACING RIGHT NOW.
THE OPPOSITION HAS INCORRECTLY
STATED THAT PENALTIES WOULD BE
PAID TO UNIONS LET ME BE CLEAR.
ANY PENALTIES LEVIED BY PURPOSE
WOULD NOT BE PAID TO ANY UNION
THEY WOULD BE PAID TO THE
GENERAL FUND. DURING
EMERGENCIES HAVING ACCURATE AND
TIMELY INFORMATION IS ESSENTIAL
WHETHER THE STATE IS FACING
WILDFIRES MASS SHOOTINGS OR
PANDEMIC VIRUSES WE IN THE
PUBLIC ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
EXPECT OUR PUBLIC SERVANTS. TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE. THE CURRENT
CRISIS IS NOT GOING AWAY SOON.
AND AN EMPLOYEES COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING REPRESENTATIVE HAS
THE MORAL AND LEGAL DUTY TO
WATCH OUT FOR THE WELFARE OF
THESE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES WHO IN
TURN WATCH OT FOR THE PUBLIC'S
WELLBEING. THE CRISIS ABOUT HAS
SHOWN THAT TODAY IT IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER THAT
EMPLOYEE REPRESENTATIVES HAVE
THE ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THE ENTIRE BARGAINING UNIT AND
ENSURE WORKPLACE SAFETY FOR
OPPORTUNITY BRING THIS BILL
BEFORE YOU. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ARE TO A
WITNESSES TODAY ARE SANDRA BUT
IT'LL- FROM CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND A LOT
OF THE MARTINEZ THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF LABOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER DRAWS SO WE'LL
MOVE ON THEN TO THE LEAD-
SUPPORT WITNESSES FIRST- MS
BERRY EARLY THROUGH THERE YOU
MAY PROCEED. FOR BUT MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FINGERPRINT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION ARE CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL. SENATOR
GLAZERS FADDISH TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY TO FIFTY DAYS REPRESENTED
ALLEN- HAD NOT SUBMITTED A
MONTHLY NEW HIRES. PART OF THE
CALENDAR YEARAND ANOTHER
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN LEN
HAVE LED TO SUBMIT THE FLAG
BURNING IN THE WEST BUT WAS
STILL IN JANUARY. WE NEED THE
INFORMATION TO QUICKLY
COMMUNICATE WITH OUR MEMBERS
AND ENSURE THEY HAVE SUFFICIENT
PEOPLE. ACCESS THE VIRUS
TESTING BAXEEN WORKPLACE
PROTECTIONS AND INFORM THEM OF
THEIR LAYOFFS RIGHT. PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS WOULD ONLY BE SUBJECT
TO A PENALTY OF PERPETRATORS
LEARN VIOLATION OF THE LAW AND
ANY PENALTIES COLLECTED GO BACK
TO THE STATE'S GENERAL FUND. SO
OFTEN AN OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS TO REMEDY ANY ERRORS
BEFORE A UNION COMPILED HER
CHARGE. EXISTING LAW DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE BOOKS CARE. HAVING
THIS INFORMATION HELPS US KEEP
OUR MEMBERS SAFE. THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO KEEP THE PUBLIC
SAFE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MOVE FORWARD TO EDUARDO
MARTINEZ IF YOU'RE HERE YOU MAY
PROCEED. GET TO CHECK IN. YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU JUST FINE THANK
YOU. PERFECT THANK YOU SO MUCH
EDUARDO MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR LABOR
FEDERATION PROUD TO BE HERE THE
CO SPONSOR. IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I'M JUST GONNA DO SO MANY
OF THE REMARKS BY MY COLLEAGUE
BY THE SENATOR. AMONG THE
HIGHLIGHTS COUPLE THINGS-
OBVIOUSLY THE PANDEMIC AND THE
RESULTING RECESSION HAVE MADE
THIS LEGISLATION ALL THE MORE
URGENT. NOT ONLY IS IT
DESPERATELY NECESSARY TO
WORKERS HAVE A VOICE TO ENSURE
THE ECONOMIC AND FINANCIAL WELL
BEING WHICH IS HARDLY A SURE
THING. WHAT THIS LEGISLATION
ALSO DESPERATELY NEEDED. TO
HELP KEEP OUR GREAT STATE- ARE
MEMBERS OF. EVERY DAY ON THAT
PUBLIC COULD FOR YOU. ENSURING
ESSENTIAL EMPLOYEES HAVE MET
THIRTY P. P. OUTLINED
IMPLEMENTATION INTO PH BY BANK
OF PRESIDENT CLINTON CLEANING
REOPENED RIGHT- FOR MANY OF OUR
PUBLIC THEY KNOW HAD THE OPTION
TO WORK. AND AFTER THE YEAR
THEY'VE HAD BECAUSE LIKE ME. TO
THE MALL TO RESPECT THEIR VOICE-
RIGHT NOW WROTE THE JOINING
YOUR NEW KITCHENS. A QUICK NOTE
ON THE OPPOSITION OF A GROUP
LISTED OPPOSITION HAVE OPPOSED
THE PREMISE THAT PUBLIC.
ORIENTATION THE BEGINNING. SOME
FAMILIES NOT SURPRISING TO SEE
THEM LISTED INTO- IN OPPOSITION
TO SB TWO SEVENTY. HOWEVER WE
DO FIND OURSELVES IN THE
FORTUNATE POSITION THAT MOST OF
THEIR INDIVIDUAL PUBLIC
EMPLOYER MEMBERS DO NOT AGREE
WITH THEIR OPPOSITION. BY ALL
ACCOUNTS MOST PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
NEED TO RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING OR AT
LEAST RECOGNIZE AND RESPECT THE
LAW THIS LOGIC LEGISLATURE
PASSED SEVERAL YEARS AGO. FOR
MOST PUBLIC EMPLOYERS SB TWO
SEVENTY WILL CHANGE NOTHING.
HOWEVER FOR THE MINORITY OF
THOSE PUBLIC IMPERFECT STILL
REFUSED TO COMPLY WITH THE LAW.
SB TWO SEVENTY CAN BE A. GAME
CHANGER FOR THOSE WORKERS.
CREATE A PROFIT TO THE ALBUM
ISSUES. IF NEEDED HOME PUBLIC
AND CAN. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION WE
ASK I PUT. THANK YOU MISS
MARTINEZ SOON WE'RE NOW GOING
TO MOVE ON TO THE COMMITTEE
ROOM ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THIS ROOM WHO WISH AND
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO SEVENTY. A SEEN NONE WILL
ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE YOUR FULL
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. YOU SEE
NONE WILL MOVE BACK TO DAVID OR
MODERATOR. AND ASKED IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS. WILLING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO
SEVENTY. BUT WE CAN BEGIN BUT
WE WOULD APPRECIATE YOU LETTING
US KNOW HOW MANY ARE IN THE
QUEUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
SEVEN IN THE QUEUE. OKAY THANK
YOU AND CLEARLY YOU ARE NOT
PERMITTED. WITH THE POLICE OF
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU BUT I AM TO ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WOULD BE STANFORD ON
BEHALF OF THE FBI YOU
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE. STE THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT TO FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS THE AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION MACHINISTS AND
IFTTT LOCALS TWENTY AND TWENTY
ONE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT TO FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOURTEEN HUNDRED YEARS
WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURKE MEGHAN'S TO WORK
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN TO
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
INTERPRETERS AND THE UNITED
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES BOTH IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN TO
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS RON RAPP ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR
APPRECIATE THAT- WE WILL. COME
BACK NOW IN FULL THIS PROCESS
FOR ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES I
DON'T SEE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS IDENTIFIED. OF SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SENATE BILL TWO
SEVENTY. IN THIS COMMITTEE ROOM.
C. KNOWN STEPPING FORWARD WE
WILL GO TO YOUR FULL ROOM-
ACCORDING TO MY SCREEN AND
THERE'S NOBODY OVER THERE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY AT THIS TIME-
WE WILL MOVE BACK TO THE
MODERATOR. IN ASKING IF THERE
ARE ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
QUEUED UP TO TESTIFY- ON SENATE
BILL. TWO SEVENTY AND IF SO
PLEASE IDENTIFY THE NUMBER OF
PERSONS. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWO SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE FIVE IN Q. IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR OUR
FIRST COMMENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ORDER FIRST COMIC COMES
FROM NINE TO TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SURE MEMBERS ISN'T DOING
GIBBONS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
AND OPPOSITION- I'D ALSO LIKE
TO- LITTLE SOMETHING FROM THE
COMMENTS MADE- THAT THE SENATE
ARE EXCUSE ME MODERATOR FIVE
DURING THIS PORTION OF THE
TESTIMONY WE CAN ONLY HEAR. A
NAME AFFILIATION. AND SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. APOLOGIZES A
SINGLE EVERYONE HAVE TO BE FOR.
THANK YOU FOR TRYING TO FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT. BY
TWO FOUR FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ABOUT WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU RYAN TO THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OR JUST UNDER HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY
RESPECTFULLY. THANK YOU RYAN TO
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
VERY ARE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHANGE NOT
CIRCULAR ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC WITH INNOVATION
SOLUTIONS IN MANAGEMENT AND IS
IT POSSIBLE TO MAKE A BRIEF
COMMENT SINCE WE DID NOT HAVE A
NEED TAPPED THE FIRE WE HAVEN'T
TAKEN THE TWO MINUTES. I KNOW
IT'S NOT POSSIBLE TO DO THAT.
BY I PROPOSE TO OF WE HAVE KEEP
THE TIME CONSTRAINTS DURING
THESE MEETINGS FOR PUBLIC
SPEAKERS. EVEN THROUGHOUT AND
WE HAVE TO DO OUR BEST TO DO
THAT- HAS TO DO WITH A LOT OF
LEGAL ISSUES AND FAIRNESS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WILL WILL
COME BACK. TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY DISCUSSION OF COMMENTS BY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. SEEN-NONE- WE CAN. MOVE TO SENATOR
TO RUSSELL AND PASSIVE SHE IS
PREPARED TO CLOSE. YES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THIS IS
VERY SIMPLE- ACTUALLY WE
SHOULDN'T EVEN BE WASTING OUR
TIME BECAUSE ALL WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE IS ENFORCING A LAW
THAT ALREADY EXISTS SO I REALLY
WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR TO
RUSSELL ON. WE CAN ENTERTAIN A
MOTION- ON THE BILL. SENATOR
NEWMAN WAS OUR MOTION FROM YOU
ON THE BILL AS CHAIR PROMOTION.
THANK YOU A SENATOR NEWMAN HAS-
MOVED THE BILL AND WILL CALL
FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE NO THANK
YOU. THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY SENATOR
CORTEZ EIGHTY NINE AND A CORTES
THE ICE CENTER- CHAU FOLK
STAINED. SENATOR CHAU BOCA NOT
VOTING CENTER DORADO. SENATOR
REID SO HI CENTER LAYERED.
SINCE SENATOR NEWMAN HI SENATOR
NEWMAN AYE THAT MOTION IS.
THREE TWO ZERO- WE'LL KEEP THE
BILL ON CALL. THANK YOU AND WE
WILL KNOWN MOVED TO SENATOR
GONZALEZ OF CENTER CONSOLES IS
HERE AND SHE IS WELCOME. HI YOU
ARE WELCOME TO PRESENT TO YOUR
BILL SB THREE THIRTY EIGHT AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU. SHARE AND
MEMBERS LABOUR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS- I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT S. B. THREE THREE EIGHT
WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE
TO PROTECT ESSENTIAL FRONT LINE
TRUCK DRIVERS AT CALIFORNIA'S
PORTS WERE STILL WORKING HARD
EVERY SINGLE DAY. DURING THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC. FOR
TRUCK DRIVERS HAVE BEEN A TORY
ASLI EXPLOITED BY BAD ACTORS IN
THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY THESE BAD
ACTORS HAVE ROUTINELY
MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS TO CUT
COSTS WRONGFULLY EXCLUDE
WORKERS FOR MINIMUM WAGE.
WORKERS COMPENSATION AND THE
RIGHT TO JOIN A UNION. DURING
THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC
MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS HAVE ALSO
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE SICK DAYS AND BASIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY PROTECTIONS
AS SIMPLE AS PP. EVEN THOUGH
MISS CLASSIFICATION IS ILLEGAL
IT IS OFTEN CHEAPER FOR TRUCK
COMPANIES TO SETTLE WAGE CLAIMS
FOR PENNIES ON THE DOLLAR THAT.
TO PROVIDE THEIR WORKERS WITH
THE PROTECTIONS AND PAY THAT
THEY DESERVE. SB THREE THREE
EIGHT ADDRESSES ITS ONGOING
PROBLEM BY BUILDING OFF OF
EXISTING LAW. SB FORTINO TO.
MOURN TRUCKING COMPANIES THAT
WALK AWAY FROM UNPAID CLAIMS
GET ADDED TO A JOINT LIABILITY
BAD ACTOR LIST THE EXISTING LAW
HAS BEEN IMPORTANT IN STOPPING
BAD ACTORS FROM WALKING AWAY
FROM AND PAYING. FROM PAINT-
FROM UNPAID WAGE CLAIMS EXCUSE
ME BUT IT DOES NOT PROTECT
WORKERS HEALTH AND SAFETY OR
ADDRESS SYSTEMIC MIS
CLASSIFICATION PROBLEMS. SB
THREE THREE EIGHT ALSO
ADDRESSES THE FAILINGS AND
PROTECTS WORKERS HEALTH AND
SAFETY BY ADDING TRUCKING
COMPANIES TO THIS LIST IF THEY
GET A FINAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
VIOLATION FROM CAL OSHA. OR
ANOTHER STATE OR LOCAL ENTITY.
THE BILL ALSO READ OUT SYSTEMIC
BAD PRACTICES BY ADDING PRIOR
OFFENDER TRUCKING COMPANIES TO
THE BAD ACTOR LIST AS WELL. AND
BY REQUIRING COMPANIES TO
CONDUCT AN AUDIT TO SHOW THAT
THEY HAVE FIX THE UNDERLYING
PROBLEM IN ORDER TO GET OFF THE
LIST. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
TODAY I HAVE PORT OF LA TRUCK
DRIVER ONE CARLOS HIDALGO. AND
RON HODEIDAH DIRECTOR OF THE
PORT DIVISION OF THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
TEAMSTERS AND PRESIDENT OF THE
L. A. COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR. THANK AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR AND-
CAN YOU INDICATE WHO WILL BE
TESTIFYING PERSONA YOU SEE
THAT.MISTER IS HERE IN PERSON
I SHOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT-
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU-
CHAIRMAN CORTESE AND
DISTINGUISHED SENATE LABOR
COMMITTEE CALIPH CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTS OUR NATION'S ECONOMIC
ENGINE PORT CARGO GENERATES
BILLIONS FOR SHIPPERS AND
RETAILERS LIKE AMAZON. WE HAVE
SEEN RECORD PROFITS IN THE
MIDST OF THIS PANDEMIC CONTRAST
THAT WITH THE MEN AND WOMEN
TRANSPORTING THESE GOODS FROM
THE PORCH OF THE WAREHOUSES
ALMOST ENTIRELY IMMIGRANT
WORKERS MOST OF THESE TRUCK
DRIVERS ARE MISCLASSIFIED AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS YOU'LL
HEAR FROM MR JUAN CARLOS HE GOT
A LITTLE MISS CLASSIFICATION
UNLAWFULLY RODS TO THEIR RIGHTS
THEIR WAGES AND LIFESAVING
PROTECTIONS. FOR TRUCK DRIVERS
ARE TRAPPED IN WHAT THE USA
TODAY INVESTIGATION TERMED
MODERN DAY IN VENTURED
SERVITUDE THE TEAMSTERS HAVE
BEEN FIGHTING FOR FAIRNESS
REPORT DRIVERS FOR DECADES AND
I ALSO HAVE MADE THIS A
PRIORITY AT THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FEDERATION OF LABOR.
THIS IS A MODEST BILL
CONSIDERING HOW EXPENSIVE THE
EXPLOITATION OF PORT TRUCK
DRIVERS IS BANNED CONSIDERING
THE BILLIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE OFF THEIR BACKS THIS IS A
MODEST BILL IN LIGHT OF DRIVERS
WHO CONTRACTED QUOTE WHICH
BROUGHT IT HOME TO THEIR
FAMILIES AND EVEN LOST THEIR
LIVES THIS BILL IS SIMPLY ABOUT
JUSTICE AND DIGNITY FOR
WORKERS. I ASK. YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CAN REMOVE
ON NOW IS A UNDERSTAND IT TO
ONE. HI CAROL. I BELIEVE HE HAS
AN ACTOR PROTECTION AS WELL. AT
THE VERY END OF THE- THAT'S
FINE WHICH IS WITH THE
TRANSLATION THE NORMAL
LIMITATION WE PUT ON THIS TWO
MINUTES BUT WHAT TWO MINUTES
FOR THE TRANSLATORS WILL ALSO
WE HAVE THAT AVAILABLE TO US
THANK YOU. THE NUMBER IS ONE
CURRICULA YES IT LOOK AT ALL IS
THERE A SEVENTY ON U. S. B. ONE
THAT'S WHAT THE CALIFORNIA IS
POSTECOGLOU. ASSISTING CORNERS
COMMITTEE AT OUR CORPORATE
ACCOUNTING OF CONNECTION CASE
PROPIONIC PUT US ON THE MIMI
CHEN IS A LOT OF GEMMA THAT
UNIVERSAL LOGISTICS QUALITY.
THIS WAS ELECTED OUR YOUNG A
LOT OF THE UNIVERSAL JUSTICE GO
CONTAINER CONNECTION. BUT TO
SEE THIS IS CAMPUS THE PERSON.
YOU'RE NOT ASKING MORE MARKET
ROSE. HOW MUCH OF IT IN THE
SEARCH OF PUT THEM IS GOING TO
KNOW. YOU KNOW THE- HERE JUST
THIS IS A SPORT TO THE SIDE.
YOU KNOW. AS THE WHEN THEY-
MENTAL IMAGE THE MUCH OF IT IS
BECAUSE JONES. MINUS ABOUT THE-
THEY TOPIC IS. QUO CONNECTIONS
ECONOMIST OF THE RICHARD.
KAMALA IT'S AN ITEM. LAW
ANGELES CA THIRTY THOUSAND. BUT
IT'S ALMOST INDEPENDENT THIS
ALL OF THE NUMBERS. THAT REALLY
DOES GET THE NUMBERS CáC
ELEVEN DOESN'T IMPRESS OF.
MONIES PROMISED A SPOKEN
ENGLISH USE. OF INOTES ALMOST
COMMON. QUICK IT'LL PROPEL
SINCE PROTECTION OF THEIR OWN
EMPLOYER. WHEN THE
CORRESPONDING UP WITH THE
COMPENDIUM REPORT THAT THE
CHRISTMAS PROTECTIONIST.
RHETORIC HOSTED A LOOPHOLE.
WHICH AT THE PERCENT OF THE
MARKET UP ASAP. IF WILL MOMENT
DEVELOPMENT TAKES THE CENTER
BUT I MEAN FOR ME THAT. THIS
PERCENT AT THE BUT I MEAN FOR
MY DAUGHTER. THE BOTTOM WAS A
BUT I DON'T EVEN SEE THE-
SOLICITOR THE SIMPLY OPEN AT
THE MOMENT THAT THAT IS MESSES
UP THEN IT'LL BENEFIT YOU.
BETTER THE LED THE ABILITY THEN
STEP OUT OF IT IF YOU'VE GOT
COMMITTEE CASTLE. BUT IT BECOME
ACCUSTOMED YEAH THE INCOME
BRACKET FOR EXAMPLE L. HOW
MESSY COMPING UP CONNECTIONS TO
GET BACK ON THE MECHANISM AT
THE MOMENT. THE GERMAN THE MAIN
DIPPING. BUT THE NUMBERS
PROTECTION OF THE SALUTE YOU
SIMPLY THAT THE COMPAGNON ALSO
BELIEVE OPTIMUM CONSTRUCTIVE.
BUT IT SHOULD CONSIDER. THE
COMPANY MUST APPROPRIATE PP.
THE COMPANY AT THE TOP OF MY
MEDICAL STUFF GOING THROUGH A
WHOLE WILL BE USED TO WAS
BITTERLY SADDAM THURMOND YOU
MISS A LONGER POSSIBLE. TO GET.
OF YOUR OWN PHONE THE OTHER
IMPEDIMENT UP OUT. MAYBE
THAT'LL ASSIST US HE WAS
DISASSEMBLING LOS US. PRESENT
DOING NAKED COUNTY COLUSA.
WOMAN COMPANION AUTHORIZED THAT
THE MYTHOLOGICAL FILM
ESPECIALLY. CONTAINER
CONNECTION DAVID YES I'VE HAD
HOPE SOMEONE WHO. ARE DEALING
WITH THE LOCAL ABOUT EMERGENCY
VEHICLES WHICH AFRAID IS A
MUST. MUCH OF BASIS.
DEVELOPMENT AT THE STATION WAS
THE LONGEST CURRICULA COMPANY
IBM ACTIVITY BECAUSE THE OUTAGE
OFFICE. THE COMMISSION LOL
INCLUSO TO LOOK AT THEM IN A
CONTAINER CONNECTION K. FED
IDEA SAID. NEGOTIATION
CALIFORNIA'S LIKE IF I GOT TO
LOOKING AT ALL. THE COMING.
OUT
IN OCTOBER WE SHOULD. THE LIST
WE LOOK AT WHAT THEY SEE AS
THIS PROCESS FOR ME. BECAUSE
CAN OF TRANSLATION PLEASE. IF
YOU COULD PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AS WELL THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR THE RECORD- JESSICA
DERMATOLOGIC ANGELES ALLIANCE
FOR NEW UPON ANY. MY NAME IS
JUAN CARLOS HIRONDELLE M. AND A
TRUCK DRIVER FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS AND LIVE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WITH MY WIFE AND
FOUR CHILDREN. FIVE YEARS AGO I
STARTED WORKING FOR CONTAINER
CONNECTION WHICH IS OWNED BY
BILLION DOLLAR CORPORATION
CALLED UNIVERSAL LOGISTICS
HOLDINGS. YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE
HEARD OF UNIVERSAL OR CONTAINER
CONNECTION BUT YOU FOR THEIR
CUSTOMERS RICH COMPANIES LIKE
WALMART AND ROTH. AS DRIVERS WE
HAVE CONTAINERS FULL OF THEIR
MERCHANDISE IN THE PORTS OF LA
AND LONG BEACH TO THEIR
WAREHOUSES. FAMILY DRIVERS LIKE
ME ARE GETTING OUR SHARE THAT
WEALTH CONTAINER CONNECTION
DENIES US OUR BASIC RIGHTS LIKE
MINIMUM WAGE. THEY DO THAT BY
CALLING US INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS BUT WE'RE
INDEPENDENT IN NAME ONLY. WE
HAVE TO FOLLOW THE COMPANY
RULES. WE DON'T RUN OUR OWN
BUSINESSES BUT JUST LIKE ANY
OTHER EMPLOYEES EXCEPT WITHOUT
THE PROTECTIONS WHEN THE
PANDEMIC HIT EXPERIENCE JUST
HOW VITAL THOSE PROTECTIONS
ARE. WORK DROPPED BY 80% LAST
SPRING AND IS A REAL STRESSFUL
TIME FOR MY FAMILY ESPECIALLY
WITH MY OLDEST DAUGHTER
PREPARING TO GO TO COLLEGE I
APPLIED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT BUT IT
TOOK OVER THREE MONTHS TO GET
BENEFITS. BUT I GAVE THE EDT
ALL THE EVIDENCE TO PROVE MY
CASE AND THE E. D. FOUND THAT I
AM AN EMPLOYEE. STILL CONTAIN A
CONNECTION KEEPS PAYING ME WITH
THE TEN NINETY NINE IN CALLING
ME INDEPENDENT. WE HAVE NO
HEALTH AND SAFETY PROTECTIONS
EITHER. THE COMPANY IS NOW
MAKING A SIGN A CONTRACT TO SAY
WE HAVE TO PROVIDE THEIR OWN
PP. MY COWORKER MANUEL GOT COVE
IT AND WAS HOSPITALIZED FOR
OVER A MONTH LAST YEAR. HE
DIDN'T EVEN GET A SINGLE PAID
SICK DAY. BECAUSE THE SITUATION
IS SO DANGEROUS I FELT A
CALLOUS TO COMPLETE TOGETHER
WITH A CO WORKER LAST MONTH.
THE DATA CONNECTION SHOULD KNOW
BETTER IT HAS BEEN CUT MISS
CLASSIFYING DRIVERS MANY TIMES.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN A LONG BEACH
JUDGE FOUND THAT THE COMPANY
HAD MISCLASSIFIED ELEVEN
DRIVERS. THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
EVEN HAD TO ORDER CONTAINER
CONNECTION TO STOP DOING
BUSINESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA UNTIL IT PAID OTHER
FINAL JUDGMENTS. WAGE THEFT.
UNSAFE WORKING CONDITIONS NO
SAFETY NET THIS IS THE REALITY
OF THOUSANDS OF POOR DRIVERS
LIKE ME. AND IT DOESN'T JUST
HURT US IT HAS OUR FAMILIES AND
HURTS OUR COMMUNITIES. THAT'S
WHY WE NEED LAWS. LIKE THESE TO
PROTECT WORKERS AND HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE COMPANIES LAKE
CONTAINER CONNECTION OF OUR
CUSTOMERS. THANK YOU TO SENATOR
GONZALEZ FOR INTRODUCING THIS
BILL WE ASK FOR YOUR I'D VOTE
FOR A FAMILY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE WILL MOVE
NOW TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM
VISITS OR ANYONE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. SEE ONE
STEP FORWARD- PETER THE
OVERFLOW ROOM. I SEE NO IN
THEIR- INTERESTED IN SPEAKING-
WILL COME BACK THROUGH THE
MODERATOR ASKED MODERATOR. TO
PLEASE QUEUE UP. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OF SB THREE THREE
EIGHT AT THIS TIME AND WE
APPRECIATE. HEARING OF A NUMBER
OF WITNESSES THAT ARE IN THEIR
QUEUE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE
THREE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT SEVEN
IN Q. FOUR TRYING TO THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON CARE MEMBERS CAN
WEIGHING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIANS WANTED LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT TO FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE DOES NOT
BE HAPPY CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IT'LL JUST
BE ONE MOMENT FOR NEXT COMMENT.
BLAINE TWO SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
EDUARDO MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
AND SPORT. THANK YOU. AND NEXT
DOOR TO ONE TO THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON BEHALF OF
BIRTH JUSTICE COURT. THANK YOU
IT'LL BE ONE MOMENT FOR NEXT
COMMENT. BORDERLINE CHIU FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS THE BEST TELEPHONE
SURVEYS I'M A BOARD MEMBER WITH
LATINOS IN ACTION AND WE
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE ONE NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JEREMY ARNOLD ON BEHALF
OF CLERGY AND LAITY UNITED FOR
ECONOMIC JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MICHAEL
CARRICK'S PRESIDENT AND
ARGUMENT CRITICAL OF LOS
ANGELES. CALLING AT THE PORT OF
SB THREE THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
WE ASSUME WILL MOVE ON AND I'LL
TO OPPOSITION WITNESSES
SEVENTY. FIVE BELIEVE FOR THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WOULD BE.
CHRISTIAN MOTOR AND ROMO TREES
A MISTER SHIMODA. DO YOU WANT
TO PROCEED PLEASE THANK YOU
WELCOME S. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTIAN OUT OF
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION- THREE YEARS AGO WE
WORK WITH THE SPONSORS ON THIS
BILLS PREDECESSOR SB FORTINO
TOO AND WE'RE PLEASED TO
ALTERNATELY REMOVE OPPOSITION.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON SB
THREE THREE EIGHT IN ITS
CURRENT FORM WHERE IS SB
FORTINO TO SPECIFICALLY
TARGETED BAD ACTORS WHO WALK
AWAY FROM OBLIGATIONS TO PAY
WAGE CLAIMS SB THREE THREE
EIGHT AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED IS
SO BROAD THE COMPANY COULD BE
PUBLICLY LISTED ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR'S WEBSITE
AND EFFECTIVELY SHUT DOWN FOR A
WIDE RANGE OF CLAIMS REGARDLESS
OF SEVERITY. WHETHER THE
INITIAL CLAIMS ARE VIOLATIONS
WERE ULTIMATELY PATER ABATED
WITH THE CLAIMS OCCURRED DAYS
ARE YEARS APART AND BEFORE THE
EMPLOYER HAS A REASONABLE
OPPORTUNITY TO ABATE HAZARDS OR
EXERCISE RIGHTS TO APPEAL AND
WITH RESPECT TO PROTECTING
WORKPLACE HAZARDS WE WOULD
HIGHLIGHT THE CALLOUS YOU MAY
ALREADY ISSUE ORDERS
PROHIBITING USE OR SEEK
TEMPORARY RESTRAINING ORDERS
AGAINST COMPANIES WILL
COMPANIES. WHERE THERE IS A
FINDING OF IMMINENT DANGER AS
YOU KNOW SHOPPERS IN
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
RETAIL AND MANUFACTURING
SECTORS ARE FACING
UNPRECEDENTED BOTTLENECKS IN
AMONG MANY OTHER ISSUES
TRUCKING CAPACITY LAST MAY
STRAINED THESE- SECTORS
COLLECTIVELY CONTRIBUTE ONE
THIRD OF THE STATE'S ECONOMY
AND JOBS. AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
SB THREE THREE EIGHT WILL ONLY
ADD TO ONGOING CHALLENGES BY
EFFECTIVELY SHUTTING DOWN
TRUCKING COMPANIES MAKING EVERY
EFFORT TO COMPLY WITH THE LAW
FINALLY WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS FOR
REACHING OUT TO DISCUSS THIS
BILL BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM ON A
REASONABLE RESOLUTION TO
CONTINUE TO TARGET BAD ACTORS
WHILE AVOIDING UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES FOR CALIFORNIA. IS
A CRITICAL SUPPLY CHAINS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THE OTHER
LEADOFF. WITNESS TO BE RAW
MOTOR IF YOU'RE HERE YOU MAY
PRESS. YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ROB MATRICULATE THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE ARE.
ALSO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THAT
FEATURES THIRTY EIGHT I'D SAY
THAT MY COLLEAGUE THE TRUCKERS
WE TO BE CLEAR WE CERTAINLY DO
NOT DISAGREE WITH THE
DISCUSSIONS OF ADDRESSING BAD
ACTORS IN THE STATE AND
CERTAINLY THE EXAMPLES. GIVEN
WERE UNACCEPTABLE WHICH THAT
SHOULD GUIDE BY NECESSARY
REQUIRED. OF A NINETEEN WEEKLY
ACCORDING TO THE- CODE NINETEEN
AVERAGES REGULATIONS CERTAIN
ACCEPTABLE- BUT ADVOCATE BY
CREDIT. THANK YOU MISSTATED BY
CHRIS. THE CONCERN WITH THE
TEXT LANG HERE ON WERE BACK
STAFF THERE AND- WHICH I WOULD
LIKE TO THANKS STAFF FOR AND
HOW DID YOU ARE RIGHT NOW. ONE
NOTABLE. WHICH THE MAJORITY ON.
WHILE THE FACT THAT WE'RE- FOR
EXAMPLE FOR THE HELLO SHOULD
VACATION. CAL ADDITIONAL ISSUE
EVEN IF IT IS RECTIFY. UNDER
THE BILL RIGHT THE ISSUE WITH
THE BAY AND FINDER. AT THAT
POINT YOU'D STILL BE TACK THE-
AND DURING THE SPELL IT IS NOW
WAY THAT YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE A
GOOD FAITH TEMPLE COMMITTED.
AND FIX THAT RIGHT DIDN'T NO
GET OFF THAT LET THE BECAUSE OF
THE ACTUAL. BY THAT THIS POINT-
WE REMAIN OPPOSED WHETHER I'D
LIKE TO FLY IT BUT- THANK YOU
MAY NOW ALSO RIGHT. IS THAT
THERE'S A- THAT DEAL AT END.
BUT COME TAKE OFF THIS LIST. WE
HAVE SOME CONCERN THAT HE'LL AT
THE BILL TO UP THE INSPECTION.
MIGHT CREATE A BACK. FOR
COMPANIES WHO HAVE MOVED OUT
WITH IT AND ADDRESSED THE- SO
BECAUSE- SEXUAL CONCERNS LIKE
THAT THIS TIME OPPOSED TO HOPE
FOR THOSE CAN BE RESOLVED.
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU-
WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK TO THE
CAN ROOM ASKED THERE'S ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO. IN TO THE BILL
HERE IN COMMITTEE ROOM. POLICE
FORWARD SEEN- TO THE OLD ROOM.
OTHERS NO WHO WISHES SPEAKING
OFF. TO THE BILL THERE. BACK TO
THE MODERATOR. MODERATOR WE CAN
NOW HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES BY TELECONFERENCE.
PLEASE QUEUE THEM UP AND LET US
KNOW HOW MANY THERE ARE. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE THREE IN Q. OVER
TRYING TO SIXTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DON'T HAVE A NUMBER
THAT YOU'RE SECURING YOUR WITH
AGRICULTURAL COMPONENT
CALIFORNIA WITH THE ONLY WOULD
LIKE THE MANDATE. GIVEN THE
PRIOR COMMENTS THANK YOU MUCH.
THANK YOU I HAVE TO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS IN HERE IT'LL JUST BE
ONE MOMENT FOR THE NEXT COMMENT.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TOTAL BOTH
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CITRUS
MUTUAL CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION WITH A POST ABOUT
THE MEDICAL PORTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT FOR THE
NEXT COMMENT. THANK YOU TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS BRIAN
LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
LOS AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MOTOR ROOM WILL COME BACK
TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
FOR DISCUSSION COMMENT THE
CENTER DRAWS A- YES. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO
THANK. ON THE AUTHOR VERY MUCH
OFFER BRING IN THIS BRINGING UP
THIS ISSUE. ONE OF ACT MR
HIDALGO FOR- TRAVELING TO
SACRAMENTO AND MR THAT ARE. AND
COMMEND THE TEAMSTERS FOR
CONTINUING TO WORK HARD YEAR
AFTER YEAR. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE TRUCK DRIVERS AT SOME
POINT IN THE FUTURE. ARE
TREATED. BOMB WITH ALL OF THE
RESPECT THAT THEY DESERVE FOR
WHAT THEY DO FOR OUR STATE'S
ECONOMY- IT'S AMAZING TO SEE.
ENTIRE INDUSTRIES I'M- BECOMING
MORE ACQUAINTED WITH THE
GARMENT WORKER INDUSTRY AND HOW
WE HAVE TO. OF FOLLOW THE CHAIN
OF LIABILITY BECAUSE-
CONTRACTORS AND SUBCONTRACTORS
ARE USED OVER AND OVER. TO HIDE
ON THE REAL RESPONSIBILITY. AND
IT'S SIMILAR WITH MISS
CLASSIFICATION SO. HERE WE ARE
IN THIS DAY AND AGE OF TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND WE'RE STILL.
LOOKING THAT THISENORMOUS. GAP
BETWEEN THE COMPANY THE WEALTH
IS BEING CREATED. AND ALL OF
THESE THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
OF. TRUCK DRIVERS WHO CAN'T
EVEN GET THE BASICS I HAVE A
BILL- RELATED TO THIS IN THE
SENSE OF HOW MISS
CLASSIFICATION. DENIES THESE
TRUCK DRIVERS THE ABILITY TO
COLLECT UNEMPLOYMENT. SO IT
CAN'T COLLECT UNEMPLOYMENT
THERE'S NO SAFETY NET FOR THEM.
THEIR MISCLASSIFIED WHEN IT
COMES TO THE THEIR LIABILITY. I
MEAN IT'S JUST A EXAMPLES OF
THIS OVER AND OVER AND IT'S NOT
SHAMEFUL. TO DEFEND AN ENTIRE
INDUSTRY WILL WE HOULD BE
DOING ALL WE CAN. FOR THOSE
WORKING HARD WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN TO BE ABLE TO JUST GET. A
LITTLE BIT OF THE FRUITS OF
THEIR LABOR SO. I COMMEND YOU
ALL THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
AND- I MOVE. THE BILL. THANK
YOU THIRTY CENTER WILL BACK FOR
A- DISK OR CALL. NUMBER SURE I
DO HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
FOR YOU- BUT BEFORE I DO THAT
BRUNETTE SWITCH A LITTLE BIT IN
SPANISH FIRST OF ALL- SAN JUAN
CARLOS DRESSES BUT OTHER THAN
YOU KNOW I KEEP GOING FEZ'S
WHATEVER THOSE TESTIMONIALS.
THAT **** BORDER AND I DON'T
HAVE A LOOK AT A SINGLE SESSION
AN ESQUIRE IS THAT OUT OF A
HIGH HE COULD NOT MUCH. COMMENT
I DO WE HAD THAT WAS IN THIS BY
YOUR THE ME BUT I WITH-
COMPLAIN THAT ANOTHER LOS AND
ONE OF THE- SOON AS WELL AS AS
DISTINCT COOPER WHO THE MIDDLE.
BUT THE EXPECTED SA I STAY I
STASHED GOT MORE LOOKING JUST
BE DONE EAT THAT FATAL. WITH
THEM HAVE BEEN A LOT IT IS A
HUNDRED THIRTY E. THE COURT BUT-
AND CONDO I INFILL SITE LOOK AT
THE MOST IN. AND WENT UP IT'LL
MASK THAT OKAY WE HAVE PLAYED
WITH THAT. I'M I'M KIND OF
CURIOUS- NOW HE AS FAR AS THE-
I AND I'M DISAPPOINTED THE CAN
THAT I HAVE WHEN YOU JUST SEE
pFORGIVE ME I AM NOT VERY
ELOQUENT ON THE AND. I'M CAN
ABOUT THE- ABILITY TO PUT
COMPANIES IN THIS LIST THAT
CREATES BEFORE HAVING THEIR DUE
PROCESS- COMING FORTH SO.
BASICALLY YOU'RE FOUND GUILTY
BEFORE- BEFORE BEING PROVEN
GUILTY IN IN IN IN. N. IN
ESSENCE AND THE COULD YOU
ADDRESS YOUR CONCERNS I MEAN
YOUR YOUR POINT OF. YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON ON THAT CONCERN
THAT I HAVE THAT WE ARE PUTTING
COMPANIES. ON THESE LISTS-
WITHOUT HAVING A DUE PROCESS
BASICALLY SAYING OKAY YOU'RE
GUILTY BEFORE PROVEN IN I MEAN
DURING YEAH YOU'RE GUILTY
BEFORE PROVEN. GUILTY ON THAT
END. AT THANK YOU- SENATOR CHOI
BOOK I APPRECIATE THAT- THE
QUESTION AND SO THE WHAT WE'RE
DOING RIGHT NOW AND AGAIN I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE WHAT THE
BILL ACTUALLY DOES SO NUMBER
ONE IT EXPANDS BAD ACTORS. THE
BAD ACTORS LIST THAT CURRENTLY-
IS IN PLAY RIGHT NOW THROUGH-
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT WHICH
BASICALLY STATES THAT IF YOU
HAVE NOT HAD IF YOU'VE BEEN
AGREE JUST EMPLOYER NOT PAYING
WAGES TO- DO THAT MISS
CLASSIFICATION. YOU'RE
CURRENTLY ON THAT LIST THIS
BILL EXPANDS THAT TO INCLUDE ON
TOP OF THE UNPAID WAGES TO
ENSURE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY IS
ALSO A FACTOR ESPECIALLY WITH
COVERED NINETEEN MANY OF THESE
WORKERS ARE NOT RECEIVING
SOMETHING SIMPLE AS PP. THEY'RE
NOT RECEIVING OUR UN SANITIZED
THERE BE ANOTHER TOUCHING AND
SANITIZED A PLACES THEY STILL
HAVE TO ABIDE BY COMPANY
POLICIES YET STILL DON'T GET
THE BENEFIT OF GETTING A WAGES
THAT ARE PAID. AND ALL OF THE
ADDITIONAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS SO THE DUE PROCESS
PART I WOULD SAY YOU KNOW THEY-
GETTING ON THAT LIST ON THE
UNPAID WAGES SIDE YOU HAVE TO
GO THROUGH THE APPEAL PROCESS
FIRST SO THEY'VE GONE THROUGH
THE APPEAL AND THEY'RE STILL.
NOT PAYING HIS WAGES BACK THIS
AGAIN JUST EXPAND THAT TO
ENSURE THAT IF THEY'RE DOING
THAT WHILE ALSO VIOLATING
HEALTH AND SAFETY THEY NEED TO
BE ON THAT LIST AND OFTEN WHAT
HAPPENS IS THE SUBTLE. BEFORE
THEY EVEN GET TO THE LIST SO
THIS IS WHAT YOU SEE ON THE
CALIFORNIA SIDE IS REALLY NOT A
FULL LIST FOR A LOT OF ACTORS
THAT ARE JUST NOT- THAT ARE
JUST KIND OF. MISSING IN THE
GAPS BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST NOT-
THEY'RE JUST PAYING THEM YOU
KNOW SETTLEMENTS AND THEY'RE
NOT. ABLE O BE ON THE LIST SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE CAPTURING
BOTH SIDES THE WAGE SIDE BUT
ALSO. THE HEALTH AND SAFETY SO
WHEN YOU SAY THAT THEY'RE BEING
THEY'RE SETTLING WHAT DOES THAT.
MEAN WHAT EXACTLY DOES NOT.
YOU'RE JUST PAYING OUT. OF
WORKERS EITHER IN THE- OR-
THEY'RE JUST NOT PAYING AT ALL.
SO WHEN USE WHEN SO WHEN
THEY'RE PAYING IT OUT ARE THE
RESOLVING THE ISSUE ARE THEY
ARE THEY ACTUALLY PAYING WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE PAYING.
FOR NOT RESOLVING THE ISSUE. OF
BACK WAGES OR HEALTH AND SAFETY.
A PUBLIC SAFETY HEALTH AND
SAFETY HAVE THE SAFETY OKAY.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT I AM GOOD FOR
RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU OTHER
CONSERVE. FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF SENIOR CENTER
GONZALEZ- IF YOU LIVE CLOSE TO
ME YEAH THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AS WELL
AND YOU KNOW WE STILL ARE
WORKING- WITH A CALIFORNIA
TRUCK TRUCKING ASSOCIATION- BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY WHAT WE WANT
TO DO IS ENSURE THAT THESE THIS
LIST IS COMPREHENSIVE AND AGAIN
IT DOES INCLUDE. HEALTH AND
SAFETY VIOLATIONS WE ARE GOING
TO BE LOOKING AT THE DUE
PROCESS ISSUE TO SEE IF THERE
IS SOME SOME SPACE THERE THAT
WE CAN WORK ON WITH THE
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY. ARE THESE
WORKERS NEED THE PROTECTIONS
AND MADE THESE ACTORS DO NEED
TO- BE ABLE TO BE ON THIS LIST
IN ORDER FOR US TO MOVE FORWARD
AND ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
JUSTICE UP. AT OUR PORTS. THAT
I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU. THE SOONER CENTER.
ON THE LITTLE UNORTHODOX BUT-
BY SURE HANDFUL OF QUESTION ARE
YOU WILLING TO TAKE A QUESTION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SO MUCH I
APOLOGIZE SOMETIMES IT JUST
GOES BY REALLY QUICK ON THAT.
HEY I HAVE TO THINK AND PONDER
FIRST- SO QUICK QUESTION ON
THE- I NEED X. A- X. A WOULD
BE- PICKS UP- WHY THIS IS NOT
APPLIED EVERY PRICES JUST FOR-
NINE UNION. I HERE THAT
UNIONIZE- COMING ARE EX FROM.
BILL NOT FROM MY LONG THAT. SO
THE PLACE TO EVERYONE ACROSS.
EVERY AGREE JUST M. ****
COMPANY. OKAY. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. OKAY FOR NOTHING FURTHER
IN- JUST FOR THE RECORD THE
SOONERS HOSTED DID CLOSE A
PREVIOUSLY WE CAN ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON THE BILL. I THINK
EARNS. ME POLITICS SENATOR ALSO
IT HAS TO MAKE THEM SIR CORRECT.
THANK. FOR IN MOTIONS MADE
PRODUCT. OUR WE'RE GONNA ASK
FOR RULE VOTE ON THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
SENATOR COURTESY BY SENATOR
CORTEZ THE AYE SENATOR- CHOKE
NO SENATOR- CHAU POKE NO
SENATOR ALSO. SAN GARAGE SO I
SAY LET. SENATORS ICE NEWMAN
ALL RIGHT SENATOR NEWMAN HI
THAT BILL IS FOR TO ONE. THREE
TWO BILLS. THANK YOU SOON.
THANK YOU. SENATOR HERTZBERG K.
THOUGHT I SAW YOU STILL INTO
THE ROOM OR HERE HERE. THERE IS.
A YOU MAY PRESENT TO YOUR BILL
AS. FIVE TWO. WITH YEAH. GERMAN
MEMBERS. S. WE IN OUR- AS
CHALLENGES EVERY DAY. AS WE
LEARN AND GROW GET BETTER. I
UNDERSTAND WHAT PARTS OF
GOVERNMENT WORK AND DON'T WORK
IT IS INCUMBENT UPON US IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH. TO ADOPT
IMPROVEMENTS. CURRENTLY WE HAVE
THE- STATE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
THAT STATEMENT DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR HAS A PROCESS- THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S BUREAU OF FIELD
ENFORCEMENT NOTICE BOTH FEES
RESPONSIBLE FOR CONDUCTING
WORKPLACE INVESTIGATIONS AND
ISSUING CITATIONS TO BAD ACTORS.
THE BAD ACTORS AND SO THE
PROCESS IS YOU REALLY GET INTO
THE DETAILS IS SOMEWHAT
CHALLENGING BECAUSE ONCE
THERE'S A FINAL JUDGMENT ONCE
INVESTIGATIONS COMPLETED ONCE
EVERYTHING'S TAKEN CARE OF AND
YOU'VE GOT A FINAL JUDGMENT
JUST LIKE IN ANY OTHER CIVIL
PROCEEDING WHAT YOU DO IS YOU
GO COLLECT ON THE JUDGMENT. ONE
OF THE PROCEDURES THAT WE
ALWAYS USE IN THE LAW IN CIVIL
PROCEDURES IS TO. PASSAGE
SUPERIOR COURT FOR AN ABSTRACT
OF JUDGMENT WE GET THE ABSTRACT
OF JUDGMENT RECORD THE JUDGMENT
ON A LIEN AGAINST THE REAL
PROPERTY WAS CHAIRMAN ENTRY
WHERE OF THAT YOUR BUSINESS
EXPERIENCE. IN LIFE. AND THE
PROBLEM IS WITH WITH THE
ABSTRACT OF JUDGMENT PROCESS IS
OFTEN SLOW. AND SO WHAT WE'VE
DONE HERE IS WE'VE CREATED A
CERTIFICATE OF LIEN. SO THAT
RATHER THAN HAVING TO GO TO THE
COURTS IS OVER AGAIN THERE'S A
FINAL JUDGMENT. WE'VE CREATED
CERTIFICATE PROCESS. AND THAT
CERTIFICATE OFF PROCESS UNDER
THIS LEGISLATION IS TO BE THAN
ACCEPTED TO BE RECORDED. AND
THEN OF COURSE THERE'S A
RELEASE PROVISION IF THAT
MATTERS PAID. BUT WHAT ENDS UP
HAPPENING IS WE'VE SEEN PART
IT'S JUST SMART GOVERNMENT WE
LEARN WE GROW AND WE GET BETTER
AND WE LEARN HOW TO IMPROVE OUR
PROCESS SEES. SECOND PIECES
THAT SOME OF THESE BAD ACTORS
BECAUSE IT TAKES SO LONG. TO
ONCE THE FINAL JUDGMENT IS
OBTAINED TO BE ABLE TO THEN.
GET ABSTRACT THEY THEN TRANSFER
THE PROPERTY PRIVATE TIME TO
TRANSFER THE TITLE BYRON TIME
TO THE RECORDATION OF THE
ABSTRACT. AND SO THE SPEED IS
CRITICAL ONCE A FINAL JUDGMENT
IS OBTAINED. AGAIN THIS DOESN'T
DO ANYTHING AT ALL THE CHANGE
PROCESS IT'S JUST ALL ABOUT
ENFORCEMENT. AND COLLECTIONS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT. THE
GOVERNMENT WHICH SEES THAT WE
HAVE A BAD ACTOR ABOUT TWELVE
HUNDRED CASES LAST YEAR. EVEN
THOUGH IT COBIT. ADD TO MAKE
THE PROCESS MORE INTELLIGENT-
SO THAT THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL. THAT'S THE REASON
WHY WE'VE INTRODUCED IT- AND I
WE HAVE- RENEE. A FROM THE
SEIU- I IT ALSO FROM THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE THERE'S
CATHERINE LEóN. WHO IS HERE ON
THE LINE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND LISTEN TO SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION- APPRECIATE THE
TIME BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SENATOR COULD MOVE
INTO LEAD SUPPORT TO-
UNDERSTAND THE FIRST A WITNESS
TO BE RENEE BY ARNOLD IS THERE
YES THANK YOU LET ME PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CAN YOU HEAR ME ALRIGHT YOU'RE
A SUDDEN CLEARS. OKAY THANK YOU
RENE PARDO AT YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA I THINK THAT SENATOR
HERTZBERG HAD ALL MY ONE.
EXPLAINED IT VERY WELL THIS IS
REAL A BILL THAT GOES AFTER
ACTOR ARE OF THE UNPAID. FOCUS
THAT OUR EXPERIENCE WE BACKED
IN SB FIVE WHICH WAS LISTED IN
THE END I. OF THE SMALL MAY
SERVICE- THE PEOPLE ARE DON'T
PAY MUCH AT TO AFTER THE BILL
PASSED WAS TALKING TO OUR
PARTNERS ARE. BOOKER CENTER TO
WORK COLLECT JUDGE. TOLD ME
THAT THEY WERE X. MILLION OF
DOLLARS PER MONTH AND ON WAGES
THAT OUR EXPECTATION THAT THIS
WAS IN THE SAME THING BUT THIS
TIME WORKERS A STRUGGLE. FOR
THEY MAY HAVE HAD A RATE STEP
OCCURRED WITHIN AND I'LL WAIT
ON THE MONEY. LIST WITH GET
THEM RIGHT SO THAT READ.
STRUGGLING SUPPORTED AND THINK
HER COULD IT AND AFTER SUPPORT.
ON THE LINE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. OKAY WELL EITHER ONE
OF YOU MAY PROCEED AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU. AT GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND AT AN
EXPERT. A CAPTAIN LEON AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE AND I AM
HERE THANK YOU FOR. EVERYTHING
THAT HAS BEEN THAT THANKS BYE
BYE. HERTZBERG AND REMAIN
STANDING BUT DEBT ON POINT NINE
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AND IF WE
WANNA WAIT TO THE END. THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU BYE WE'RE
GOING TO GO HEAD TO MOVE TO A
TESTIMONY THE COMMITTEE ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS ANYONE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
ASSENAGON WILL MOVE ON TO YOUR
FULL ROOM. AS SEEN NONE OF
LOCAL TO THE MODERATOR. OF FOR
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. HI
MODERATOR- IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IF SO YOU MAY KEEP
THEM UP THIS TIME AND PLEASE
LET US KNOW THE NUMBER. AND ARE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME WE DO
HAVE THREE IN THE QUEUE. PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU. ABSOLUTELY
FIRST WILL GO TO NUMBER TWO
SIXTY SIX TO SIXTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
TURNER EMBERS MITCH SNIDER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT. THE
NEXT TO GO TO LINE TWO THIRTY
THREE TO THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PLANET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
AND WILL NOW GO TO NUMBER TWO
FORTY ONE TO FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TRANSACTION ON BEHALF
OF THE TEACHERS IN SUPPORT. AND
ONCE YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE MR THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR- AS THE LEAD
OPPOSITION- WE HAVE NO ONE
IDENTIFIED SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO THE COMMITTEE ROOMS
DURING THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SO STEP TOWARD. THE SINGING
NUN WILL CONCLUDE YOUR FULL
ROOM- THERE ARE NO WITNESSES
THEY'RE WISHING TO SPEAK WILL
COME BACK TO THE MODERATORS.
AND ASK YOU TO QUEUE UP ANY
WITNESSES WHICH SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL HI
PLEASE LET US KNOW THE NUMBER.
AND NOW IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION. WHEN CAN LIVE IN
GERMAN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TWO IN OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NONE IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE MR THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND- SEE IF THERE'S
ANY DISCUSSION REQUEST TO BE
RECOGNIZED FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THE FIRM'S OPTION IT
ALMOST AS SOON. AS I HAVE RE
READ THE RULES. BECAUSE JOB.
NAVIGATE ALL AROUND THE RULES.
HERTZBERG YOU YOU MAY CLOSE AND
I'M SORRY. STORIES WE DO HAVE A
QUESTION. FOR ANY SIGN THE JOB
OF WELL OF COURSE FOR CLARITY
PURPOSES- WHEN YOU HAVE
MULTIPLE. ENTITIES ARE OWNERS
FOR A CORPORATION IS THE R.
THAT MEANS IS THE AMOUNT
DIVIDED AMONGST ALL ALL THE-
THE INTERESTED PARTIES ARE THE
OWNERS ARE THEY IS IT TOO IS IT
THE SAME AMOUNT FOR EVERY OWNER
HOW DOES THAT HOW DOES THAT
WORK IT DEPENDS ON WHAT THE
JUDGE IN THIS THIS IS REALLY A
POST JUDGMENT REMEDY. TO
COLLECT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PERSON WHO WHERE THERE'S BEEN A
FULL DUE PROCESS AND THEY'VE%
BEEN AWARDED JUDGMENT AND THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY COLLECT IF THE
JUDGMENT SAYS JOINED SEVERAL
THEN. THERE'S FIVE DEFENDANTS
THEY'RE ALL LIABLE ONE PERSON
HAS THE MONEY IT'S PAID AND
THEY HAVE TO SUE AMONGST EACH
OTHER OFTEN THESE JUDGMENTS ARE
PRETTY CLEAR AS TO WHO THE
DEFENDANT IS IN THE CASE WHO IS
THE GREEN PARTY AND MAKE THAT
CLEAR THOSE ARGUMENTS OFTEN IN
THE CASE WHEN THERE'S FULL DUE
PROCESS. THAT THE EMPLOYERS
WILL THEN ENGAGE IN AND SAY
WELL I DIDN'T REALLY DO IT IT
WAS THE RASO WHO DID IT. OKAY
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE. IT'S
SO SIMPLE WELL IT OR COULD BE
LAYERED WHO DID IT BUT THE
POINT THAT'S INTERNAL FIGHT
BUFFALO HUNTS THAT HAPPENS THEN
THEN THE JUDGMENT SO IT'S A
FUNCTION OF WHAT THE JUDGMENT
SAYS THIS IS JUST SIMPLY A WAY.
TO AVOID THE SCAMMER RENO'S THE
CAR BECAUSE THE PROCESS TAKES
SO LONG ME THINK HOW THAT THAT
WORKS RIGHT I MEAN THE
GOVERNMENT IS OUT THERE
SOMEBODY'S ALREADY BEEN
DETERMINED AS A PROBLEM AND WE
HAVE A PROCESS IS SO
INEFFICIENT THAT WE LET
SOMEBODY- BASICALLY SKIP OUT
FROM UNDER THE LEAN ON THEIR
PROPERTY- AND MAKE IT WORSE
THAT'S REALLY WILL ROUTE WILL
ONLY DO WITH BAD ACTORS. IN
RELIGION WITH INTELLIGENT
PROCESS TO MAKE IT WORK BETTER
AND NOT HAVE THE DELAYS BY
RECORDING ABSTRACT OF JUDGMENT.
WE COME UP THIS IDEA OF
CERTIFICATE OF LIEN. HEY
THERE'S A RELEASE A LEAN.
RELEASES THE- BILLION AGAINST
PROPERTIES YOU KNOW IN REAL
ESTATE THAT WAY IT WORKS. YEAH
AT THE END OF PROCESSES I'M
GETTING SOON PRETTY SPEEDS ARE
GOING TO BE VERY. DIFFICULT OR
THE TEACHERS TO. TELL OUR HOPE
IS I MEAN THAT'S WE'RE TRYING
TO DO WITH THIS BILL. WE'RE
TRYING TO. BRING SOME CMMON
SENSE TO AVOID THIS
EMBARRASSING PROSPECT. YOU KNOW
LAST YEAR WE HAD. ONE THOUSAND
ONE SEVENTY TWO CASES. AND TO
TRY TO SPEED IT UP AND MAKE IT
SIMPLER LESS COSTLY LESS
DIFFICULT AND MORE EFFECTIVE
ONCE THERE'S BEEN A FULL AND
FINAL HEARING. AND THE PERSON
IS DETERMINED TO BE LIABLE AND
THIS IS JUST THE COLLECTION
EFFORT AND MAKE IT WORK JUST
LIKE. ANY OF US WOULD WANT.
ONCE A JUDGE'S BEEN OBTAINED.
FOR COLLECTION PROCESS TO OCCUR
EFFICIENTLY SO ONCE AGAIN JUST
FROM REGULAR PROGRAM
UNDERSTANDING WHEN YOU HAVE
MULTIPLE. OWNERS RIGHT. IS THE
R. R. IT IS A JUDGE. EQUAL
AMONGST IS IT I. EQUAL AMONGST
EACH EACH ENTITY INVOLVED OR IS
IT DIVIDED AMONGST MULTIPLE
OWNERS OF THE BUSINESS OR
MULTIPLE BUSINESS AND REAL
ESTATE. BUSINESS AS WHOEVER DID
THIS IS AGAINST. A BUSINESS
OWNER RIGHT WHO DOESN'T PAY
THEIR WAGES IF THERE'S MULTIPLE
BUSINESS OWNERS YEAH- ARE THE-
ARE THE M. IS THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY. DIVIDED AMONGST THE BE
THE OWNERS OF THE COMPANY OR IS
IT FILED WITH ONE AMOUNT SAY
THEY OWE A THOUSAND DOLLARS IS
A DIVIDED AMONGST FOUR WITH A
NO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
EACH OR IS IT A THOUSAND
DOLLARS YOU NEED TO WHOEVER
PAYS THAT. OURSELVES A PROPERTY
FIRST AND PAYS UP TO LEAN GET
EVERYBODY OFF RIGHT. THAT'S THE
CONCEPT THE JOINT SEVERAL
LIABILITY THAT'S A CONCEPT THAT
THE PART THE DEFENDANT'S LET'S
ASSUME THAT THE PLAYERS WHO
ENGAGED IN INAPPROPRIATE
CONDUCT AND GOT A JUDGMENT
AGAINST THEM. THEY WILL ARGUE
THAT BOTH MR HURD'S PERSONA
MADE THE MISTAKE THE JUDGE AND
SHOULD BE AGAINST HIM. THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER WILL MAKE
THAT DETERMINATION. ALL THING
THIS IS TO DEAL WITH THE
ENFORCEMENT OF WHAT EVER THE
ORDER SAYS. THE ORDER SAYS
JOINT AND SEVERAL LIABILITY
AMONG THREE OWNERS. THAT MEANS
THAT WHOEVER PAYS FIRST IT'S
PAID OFF AND THE OTHER TWO
PEOPLE HAVE TO GO AFTER THAT
THAT PERSON IS GONNA BE THE TWO
PEOPLE FOR THEIR SHARE. OR MOST
LIKELY THERE'S CLARITY IN THE
PROCESS. SO THAT THE ORDER. GOT
THESE DAYS THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER ORDERS WILL
INDICATE WHO'S LIABLE. AND THEN
THE LEANS AGAINST THE PROPERTY.
THANK YOU THEY OF COURSE OF
COURSE THANK YOU. OKAY SEE AN
ORDER REQUEST TO BE RECOGNISED
HER FROM THE DAIS THE CENTERS
FOR NOW YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU I JUST AS RELIABLE THEY GET
I THINK THE QUESTION A
CLEARANCE IT'S JUST A TRYING TO
MAKE GOVERNMENT WORK BETTER AT
A TIME WHEN WE'RE ONLY GOING%
AFTER BAD ACTORS AND IS A FULL
AND FINAL HEARING OF THE
PROCESS AND WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO MAKE IT SIMPLER MORE
INTELLIGENT. AND MORE EFFECTIVE
THANK YOU THE BILL SENATOR BYRD
MOOSE THE BILL WERE PREPARED
FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE AT THIS
TIME. THERMO IS TO PASS PERSON
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY SENATOR
CORTEZ. HI AND ACCORDING AYE
SENATOR OCHO BOOK BY. SENATOR
CHAU BOGUE HI SENATOR DRAWS.
SENATOR TORONTO HI CENTER
LAYERED HI SUNDERED BLARED. OFF
CENTER LAYERED ICE CENTER
NEWMAN HI THE NEW MENAI THAT
MEASURE HAS FIVE VOTES IN THE
BILL SO THANK YOU SENATOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE MOBILE
REPORT ON ALL THE. THE WAR TO
USE IT IS AN EXAMPLE IN THIS
COMMITTEE ROOMMATES. I WANTED
TO THE CONSEQUENCE. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO SENATOR OF LABOR AND
HER BILL SENATE BILL FIVE TWO
THREE. THE WELCOME CENTER IN
YOUR WELCOME TO PRESENT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS. ALL
RIGHT I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS BILL. THIS BILL
IS PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD
SENATE BILL FIVE TWENTY THREE
EXPANDS AND MODERNIZES BIRTH
CONTROL ACCESS AND ENSURES
GREATER CONTRACEPTIVE EQUITY
STATEWIDE REGARDLESS OF AN
INDIVIDUAL'S GENDER OR
INSURANCE COVERAGE STATUS.
DESPITE THE PROGRESS MADE IN
CALIFORNIA HEALTH DISPARITIES
IN REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES
PERSIST AMONG BLACK INDIGENOUS
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR INCLUDING
DISPROPORTIONATE UNINTENDED
PREGNANCIES INFANT EMR TED MORE
MATERNAL MORTALITY AND S. T. D.
RATES. IT IS TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO MODERNIZE AND
EXPAND ITS CONTRACEPTIVE EQUITY
LAWS TO REDUCE BARRIERS TO
CONTRACEPTIVE CARE IMPROVE
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND CREATE GREATER
HEALTH EQUITY. TO THAT END SB
FIVE TWENTY THREE ACCOMPLISHES
THE FOLLOWING MAKES
CALIFORNIA'S CONTRACEPTIVE
EQUALITY LAWS GENDER NEUTRAL.
REQUIRES COVERAGE OF OVER THE
COUNTER. I AGREE- REQUIRES
COVERAGE OF OVER THE COUNTER
BIRTH CONTROL OPTIONS TO
INCREASE ACCESS IN TIME
SENSITIVE CARE EXPANDS
CONTRACEPTIVE COVERAGE BENEFITS
TO STATE EMPLOYEES AND
INDIVIDUALS ENROLLED IN
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
PLANS. AND PROHIBITS EMPLOYER
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON
EMPLOYEES CONTRACEPTIVE CHOICES
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL R. SYLVIA CASTILLO OF
ESSENTIAL ACCESS HEALTH
ANALYSTS MCKAY MEN OF THE
NATIONAL HEALTH LAW PROGRAM.
THANK YOU CENTER WILL THEN
MOVED TO YOUR SUPPORT WITNESSES
WILL BE A CUSTODIAL. YOU MAY
PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME FOR
THE CAST KIANA OKAY THE RECTOR
OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS WITH THE
CENTRAL HOW WE CAN BETTER
PROMOTE QUALITY SECTION AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE FOR
ALL AND WIENER CROWD WE ARE
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR SB FIVE
TWENTY THREE AM THANKS CENTER
LABOR FOR BEING A FAMILY
PLANNING CHAMPION AND FOR HER.
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. I THANK ACCESS OF COAST.
THE COVERAGE EQUITY ACT IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN WHICH OFFENDED
THE LABOR MENTIONED CODIFIED
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT'S BIRTH
CONTROL MANDATE INTO STATE LAW.
CALIFORNIA WAS THE FIRST DATE
COULD DO THIS AND THE MEASURE
OF THE USE OF A MODEL
LEGISLATION AND OTHER STATE.
THEN OTHER STATES HAVE ENACTED
PROVISIONS THAT WENT ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE EIGHTEENTH BIRTH
CONTROL MANDATE TO CREATE
GREATER CONTRACEPTIVE EQUITY.
FOR EXAMPLE WHILE WOMEN
ENSURING CALIFORNIA CAN I
OBTAIN STERILIZATION SERVICES
WITH NO OUT OF POCKET COSTS.
MEN STILL HAVE TO PAY COPAYS
AND COST SHARING THEME PARK
AFFECTING. AT THE TWENTY TWENTY
AT LEAST EIGHT STATES NOW
REQUIRE HEALTH PLANS TO COVER
MALE STERILIZATION SERVICES
WITH NO COPAYS. THE COSBY
NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY HALF BROTHER
ELIMINATED THE STRUCTURAL
INEQUITIES THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT YOU.
INCOME PEOPLE AND COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR AND ACCESS. CONTROL
SERVICES. A COURT REVEALED THAT
38% OF BLACK WHEN AND FORTY
FIVE OF LATINOS COMPARE 229% OF
WHITE WOMEN NOW FACE
DIFFICULTIES ACCESSING BIRTH
CONTROL AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC. SO WHAT X. COMING UP
OVER THE COUNTER BIRTH CONTROL
WILL OFFER HELP REDUCE BARRIERS
TO CONTRACEPTIVE CARE FOR THE
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS DURING
COLD THE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
BEYOND AND CREATE GREATER
CONTRACEPTIVE EQUITY WHEN
EXPANDING THE ABILITY TO OBTAIN
AN ANNUAL SUPPLY OF
CONTRACEPTIVES THIS IS THE
BENEFIT NOW EXPORTED TO MANY
BUT NOT ALL CALIFORNIANS. AFTER
BIRTH CONTROL SHOULD NOT DEPEND
ON YOUR INCOME INSURANCE STATUS
OR WHERE YOU LIVE WORK OR GO TO
SCHOOL OVER THE YEARS SEVERAL
UC UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS HAVE SUBMITTED
COMPLAINTS TO CENTRAL ACCESS
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO
GET A YEAR'S SUPPLY OF BIRTH
CONTROL CALIFORNIANS ENROLLED
IN THE KNOX KEEN HEALTHCARE
PLAN ARE ABLE TO DO SO. ONE
STUDENT REACHED OUT TO THE
STUDENT HEALTH PLAN
ADMINISTRATOR AND WAS NOTIFIED
THAT BECAUSE THE PLAN ITSELF
FUNDED THEY WERE NOT REQUIRED
TO COMPLY WITH CALIFORNIA
REQUIRING THIS COVERAGE WOW
THIS IS CORRECT IT IS
DEVASTATING FOR A STUDENT HERE
AFTER YEARS OF ATTACK THE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH DURING THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION ARE SPEAK
CAN AND MUST ADVANCE CORRECTIVE
SOLUTION. TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN GET THAT BIRTH
CONTROL THEY WANT WHEN THEY
NEED IT WITHOUT THAT WAY BACK
WHEN WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AT. FIVE
TWENTY THREE TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR. ON FEB FOR-
ELUSIVE MCCANN IS THE NEW.
WITNESS BECAUSE FINDS. ARE YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBER. MY
NAME IS WAS MCCANN AND I'M A
SENIOR WITH THE NATIONAL HEALTH
PROGRAM A PUBLIC INTEREST LAW
FIRM WITH OFFICES IN LOS
ANGELES. ET AND TRAVEL HELD.
OUR MISSION TO PROTECT AND
ADVANCE TO HELP RIGHT OF LOW
INCOME AND UNDERSERVED PEOPLE.
WE ARE VERY PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
SB FIVE TWENTY THREE AND AFTER
A GRATITUDE. TO SENATOR LATE
AFTER HER LEADERSHIP. CALPERS
CURRENTLY SPONSOR ON OF FULLY
INSURED PLANS THAT ARE SUBJECT
TO THE STATE KNOCKING AT.
INCLUDING A CONTRACEPTIVE
COVERAGE REQUIREMENT. HARPER
ALSO SPONSORS OF ALL FELL
FUNDED HEALTHCARE PLAN THAT ARE
NOT SUBJECT TO KNOX KEEN. FOR
THE FEDERAL LAW ARISSA. EXACTLY
PPL PLAN THAT ARE ADMINISTERED
BY A THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR.
INDIVIDUAL COVERED UNDER THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR ARRANGEMENT
MAY INCORRECTLY BELIEVE THAT
THEY ARE COVERED BY THE CARRIER
ADMINISTERING THE BENEFIT AND
THAT THEY HAVE THE PROTECTION
OF STATE REGULATION. WHEN IN
FACT THAT COVERAGE AND
PROTECTION LEGALLY ARE MORE
LIMITED. SELF FUNDED PLANS ARE
NOT LEGALLY HEALTH INSURANCE
FOR PURPOSES OF KNOX KEEN. THEY
OPERATE LIKE THAT IN MANY WAYS.
ASSEMBLY BEING LOCKED INTO YOUR
PLAN FOR THE YEAR. IF A STATE
EMPLOYEE AND A SELF FUNDED PLAN
DISCOVERED THAT THE PLAN DOES
NOT HAVE SUFFICIENT COVERAGE.
FOR EXAMPLE IF A MAN FINDS THAT
THE COST SHARING FOR AFFECTED
ME IS WHAT YOU HIGH I CAN OFTEN
BE A THOUSAND. YOU CANNOT JUST
CHANGE PLAN. WE WILL NEED TO
WAIT A YEAR AND THEN EXAMINE
HIS. OPTIONS DURING THE NEXT
OPEN ENROLLMENT. BUT NOW WE
HAVE TO SWITCH PLAN TO GET.
COME WE THINK IT MAKES.
COVERAGE BASEBALL AND OFFICE
PLANS. I DON'T WANT TO CLEAR
THAT THE STUDY NOT REQUIRE
INCOME OR HOW THE FED TO
PROVIDE ANY PARTICULAR. AS WELL
IMPACT ON CALPERS. TO CONTRACT
WITH PROVIDER GROUPS ARE
HOSPITAL I DO NOT WANT TO BUY
TO PROVIDE CONTRACEPTIVE
COVERAGE AT. I A MATTER OF FACT.
CALPERS KERN ONLINE ITSELF
FUNDED PEOPLE BENEFIT. WITH
THAT STORY INSURED BENEFITS.
BUT NOT A WRITTEN POLICY OR LAW
WE NEED TO MAKE IT ONE. WE WERE
FACT RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU. THREE
TWO THREE TESTIMONIUM BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ROOM IN NASCO IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WAS JUST
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. THIS AGAIN IS- S. B. FIVE
TWO THREE. C. NONE WILL MOVE TO
THE OVERFLOW ROOM. BUT SEEN
NONE THEY'RE WISHING TO TESTIFY
WILL MOVE TO THE MODERATOR AND
PASS THE MODERATOR. TO PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES
ON SB. FIVE TO THREE HIM PLEASE
LET US KNOW THE NUMBER. AND
LATER GERMAN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FIVE TWO THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE TO THREE.
LOOKS LIKE AT THIS TIME WE DO
HAVE ABOUT NINE IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU MOTOR ME PROCEEDS.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL START WITH
NUMBER TWO SEVENTY ONE TO
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CARE AND
MEMBERS COUNTY DOWN OFTEN
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL BUT THIS IS ONE OF OUR
TOP PRIORITY BILLS FOR THE YEAR.
NEXT WILL THE NUMBER TO SIXTY
TO SIXTY PLEASE GO OUT. RIGHT
SPENT ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBGYN FOR DISTRICT
NINE IN SUPPORT. THAT COULD BE
NUMBER TWO FIFTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. NOW GO TO NUMBER TWO
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
LIVE WITH MY RIGHT. THAN A PLAN
HAND TO FULLY EQUIPPED
CALIFORNIA INSTRUCT THE COURT.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. IMPACTS
FROM THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT BY MUCH. MEXICO
NUMBER TWO SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS SHANNON
OVER THE AREA OKAY ON BEHALF OF
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA WE
ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER TWO SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS WHY I AM NOT
PREPARED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. AND
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER TWO SEVENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RON
RAPP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE TWENTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE MR DRINK THANK YOU
MODERATOR- WE HAVE THE NEW
IDENTIFIED LEAD OPPOSITION-
WILL MOVE TO WITNESSES IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM TODAY. A
C. NONE OF US THE SAME OF THE
ROLLOVER ROOM STORE ROOM IS OR
ANYONE WAS SPEAKING OPPOSITION
SEEN NONE. OF BACK TO THE
MODERATOR MODERATOR TO IF YOU
CAN NOW MOVE TO- THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS OPPOSITION
WITNESSES OR TESTIMONY
EMPLOYEES QUEUE THEM UP LET US
KNOW HOW MANY THERE ARE THANK
YOU. THEN AFTER IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FIVE TWENTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION. ONE
TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION. AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
PLEASE CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR ROOMS
WILL COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AND- SEE THERE'S A DISCUSSION
AT THE COMMITTEE OR QUESTIONS
OF MINIMUM. YES SIR CENTER THE
NEWMAN THANK YOU MISTER SHARES
SENATOR LEYVA I WANT TO COMMEND
YOU NOT JUST ON THIS BILL.
WEBER ALL OF THE WORK YOU'VE
DONE THROUGH THE YEARS TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO CONTRACEPTION
AND FAMILY PLANNING SRVICES.
BOB AND IF IT'S POSSIBLE AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD I WOULD
REQUEST TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR. THANK YOU SIR LIMON WE
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU AS A CO
AUTHOR THANK YOU. MEMBERS THE
CLERK THE FOR PURPOSE CENTER
LEYVA WOULD YOU MIND-
TERRIFYING WHICH AGENCY WOULD
ENFORCE CLAIMS OF
DISCRIMINATION OR ADVERSE
ACTION FOR OBTAINING OF
CONTRACEPTIVES. WE COULDN'T SEE
WOULD ENFORCE OF SOMEONE IS
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST YES I
WOULD I SUPPOSE IT WOULD IT
WOULD DEPEND ON THE PERSON
BEING DISCRIMINATED AGAINST AND
WHERE THEY WERE BEING
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST. TWENTY
ALSO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
IF NOT DONE SENATE AVAILABLE
YOU'RE WELCOME TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. WHO IS OUR
MOTION ON THE BILL. COOL WATER-
THE BILL SIR MOVES THE BILL
COOL. THE. FOR THE MOST IS SET
FOR BE REFER TO THE CAN ON
HEALTH SENATOR CORTEZ HI
UNDERCOOKED HAS THE OFFICE
SENATOR- CHAU FOLK NOT VOTING
SENATOR ALSO. SENATE ALSO AYE
SENATOR LAYERED HI SENATOR
LAYERED I SENATOR NEWMAN HI
SENATOR NEWMAN HI. THE BILL HAS
FOUR VOTES READ THE BILLS OUT
PLEASE INTERFERE THANK YOU
MEMBERS. FOR SURE YOUR BILL IS
OF THIS UP NEXT- AND THEN- FOR
CLARIFICATION IN CASE OF PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN MONITORING THIS LATE
OR WAITING- MY BILL WHICH WAS
ORIGINALLY EARLIER ON THE
AGENDA WILL BE THE LAST BILL
WILL HERE TODAY- SO SB SIX FIVE
SEVEN. SOME RESEARCH WILL SHOW
BOTH. PARTY HI I'M LAST I WILL
BE AFTER SENATOR RITUAL BOTH IN
THE THAT WOULD BE SB THIRTY
THREE OF KICKING CLOSER SO
WITNESSES LISTENING. THEN YOU
CAN STAY HERE CENTER PLEASE-
PROTOCOL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS- QUITE EXCITED
THEY JUST HAVE THE PREVIOUS IS
THIS I'M A FRESHMAN SENATOR
PRESENTING MY VERY VERY FIRST
BILL IN FRONT OF A COMMITTEE. I
REQUEST. MY VERY B. I HOPE
YOU'RE NICE AND KIND- SO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL SIX FIVE
SEVEN FIRST I WANT TO THANK
THAT TO SAY THANK YOU TO ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT HAVE
ENGAGE WITH ME IN THIS BILL IT
IS SO IMPORTANT TO ME TOO THAT
WE GET THIS RIGHT I'M COMMITTED
TO WORKING ON THE ON THE BILL
BEFORE IT IS HEARD IN THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IF
IT PASSES THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
I'M OPEN TO HEARING COMMENTS
FROM ANY GROUP THAT HAS
CONCERNS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING WITH EVERYONE I INTEND
TO ADD CLARIFYING LANGUAGE TO
DEFINE SOME OF THE TERMS AND
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT BUSINESSES
STILL NEED TO DO ALL OF THE
CURRENT POSTINGS AT THE PLACE
OF BUSINESSES. I ALSO INTEND TO
REMOVE THE SECOND SECTION
RELATED TO THE ELECTRONIC.
SIGNATURE AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
SB SIX FIVE SEVEN AUTHORIZES
BUSINESSES WHO HAVE EMPLOYEES
THAT ARE WORKING FROM HOME OR
TELECOMMUTING TO RECEIVE
SPECIFIC EMPLOYMENT RELATED
DOCUMENTS ELECTRONICALLY. THIS
IS ESPECIALLY RELEVANT TO ALL
THE EMPLOYEES. WERE WORKING
HOPE HOME FROM HOME RIGHT NOW
AS A RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC
COVE IT HAS DISRUPTED BUSINESS
PRACTICES AND FORCE MANY
INDUSTRIES TO REWORK THE WAY
THAT THEY OPERATE IN ORDER TO
ACCOMMODATE THE ORDERS FROM THE
STATE. HOWEVER THERE ARE
CERTAIN NOTIFICATIONS THAT
EMPLOYEES MUST RECEIVE EACH
YEAR AND THERE IS NO SET WAY
FOR EMPLOYERS TO CONDUCT THAT
BUSINESS AT THIS MOMENT. SB SIX
FIVE SEVEN WILL ALLOW FOR
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE WORKING FROM
HOME OR TO A COMMUNITY TO
RECEIVE SPECIFIC EMPLOYMENT
RELATED DOCUMENTS
ELECTRONICALLY. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT ALL EMPLOYEES CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THE SAME INFORMATION.
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE IN THE
WORKPLACE. WITH ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY IS ACTUALLY HOFFMAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND JENNIFER SUPER
LOCK WITH THE SAN DIEGO SOCIETY
FOR HUMAN RESOURCE MANAGEMENT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR-
WILL MOVE TO ASHLEY HOFFMAN THE
FIRST IDENTIFIED LEAD SUPPORT
BUSINESS HE MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I BELIEVE WE
WILL HAVE NECESSITY WILL OCCUR
FIRST ABOUT OKAY. THAT WOULD BE
FINE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
HUBER LACK ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
DIEGO SOCIETY FOR HUMAN
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT ALSO NOTED
SAN DIEGO SHERMAN WE'RE ONE OF
SIXTEEN CHAPTERS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL OF SHERMAN WHOSE
MEMBERSHIP CONSISTS OF MORE
THAN THIRTY THOUSAND HR
PROFESSIONAL. IN TURN CAL
SHERMAN AFFILIATE OF THE
SOCIETY FOR HUMAN RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT FOR SHARM WHICH IS
THE FOREMOST EXPERT CONVENER
AND THOUGHT LEADER ON ISSUES
IMPACTING TODAY'S EVOLVING
WORKPLACES WITH MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND HR AND
BUSINESS EXECUTIVE MEMBERS AND
A HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
COUNTRIES. OUR MEMBERS TO SERVE
AS THE INTERFACE BETWEEN
EMPLOYEE AND EMPLOYER TAX WITH
APPLYING EMPLOYMENT LAWS
ENACTED HERE IN A REAL WORLD
CONTACT. IN THE PAST YEAR OUR
MEMBERS HAVE STILL MORE
REQUESTS THAN EVER FROM
EMPLOYEES ASKING TO
TELECOMMUTE. OUR EMPLOYEES WANT
MORE FLEXIBILITY IN THEIR WORK
ARRANGEMENTS AND MAXIMIZE TIME
THAT WITH FAMILY MINIMIZE TIME
SPENT ON THE ROAD. I CAN
BALANCE WORK LIKE NEED. IN OUR
MEMBERS WANT TO PROVIDE THE
FLEXIBILITY WHILE STILL
ENSURING OUR TEAMMATES ARE
APPRISED OF THEIR RIGHTS AND
OBLIGATIONS. UNDER SB SIX FIFTY
SEVEN REMOTE EMPLOYEES WOULD
NOT NEED TO GO INTO THE
WORKPLACE. JUST TO REVIEW
DOCUMENTS AND POSTING. NO WOULD
THEY NEED TO. THEIR HOME WITH
BURKE CULTURE. INSTEAD THEY CAN
SIMPLY RECEIVED REQUIRED.
ELECTRON SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN
WOULD ALSO PROVIDE HR
PROFESSIONALS WITH MUCH NEEDED
CLARITY THAT ELECTRONIC
TRANSMISSION IN FACT COMPLIES
WITH THE LAW. NOTABLY SB SIX
FIFTY SEVEN DOES NOT ELIMINATE
ANY REQUIREMENT TO POST NOTICES
IN THE WORKPLACE RATHER IT
CREATES A NARROW COMMONSENSE
RULE FOR REMOTE WORKERS ONLY.
AND PERHAPS MORE NOTABLY THIS
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR NEW
SOME HAVE ALREADY CONFIRMED THE
PROPRIETY OF ELECTRONIC
TRANSMISSION OF CRITICAL
WORKPLACE NOTICES FOR EXAMPLE
SACRAMENTO PAYCHECK WE'VE UNDER
SB NINETY FIVE SPECIFICALLY
PERMITS ELECTRONIC ELECTRONIC
TRANSMISSION FOR REMOTE
EMPLOYEES. WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MMHM WHO WILL GO BACK TO
ASHLEY HOFFMAN OF MISS HARPER
DID YOU WISH TO SPEAK. I GUESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS ACTUALLY HOW
OFTEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT SB SIXTY SEVEN.
DOURADO OF CURVE IT IT THAT
NEEDED THAT UP 240% OF
CALIFORNIANS RECORD STARTED
TELECOMMUTING ONE ISSUE
EXASPERATED BY THAT TRANSITION
WOULD HOW DO EMPLOYERS
DISSEMINATE REQUIRED NOTICES
THE TELECOMMUTERS. MANY POSTERS
ISSUED BY THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER DMCH REQUIRE THE
POSTERS TO BE DISPLAYED IN A
CONSPICUOUS PLACE UNEMPLOYED
FREQUENT IN THE WORKPLACE. THE
BOSTON PLAYERS WONDERING HOW TO
CONTINUE TO COMPLY WITH THESE
LAWS WERE COMPLAIN WHO'S NOW
TELECOMMUTING IS NO LONGER
FREQUENTING THE TYPICAL
WORKPLACE INFANTS LEADING MOST
OF THEIR TIME IF NOT ALL THEIR
TIME AT HOME. WELCOME LAWS
REGULATIONS EXPLICITLY SAY THAT
ELECTRONIC NOTICES THE FISHING
IN THE REGION OTHER RATHER
SILENT ON THE ISSUE. BECAUSE
THE NOTICE REQUIREMENTS ARE
SILENT AS TO WHETHER OR NOT TO
NOTICE COMESTIBLE EMPLOYERS ARE
NOW HAVING TO MAIL NOTICES THE
TELECOMMUTING EMPLOYEES TO BE
SAFE SO AS NOT TO INCREASE
PENALTIES. BUT ONLY ABOUT
PROFIT COSTLY BUT LOCAL
WORKFORCE ABOUT SEVENTEEN
MILLION THIS MEANS THAT SIX
POINT EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE WERE
HAVING TO RECEIVE A PACKET OF
PAPER WHICH IS A STAGGERING
AMOUNT OF PAPER THAT COULD
EASILY BE PROVIDED
ELECTRONICALLY. SB SIX FIFTY
SEVEN FOLLOWS THIS ISSUE
INCREASED CONSISTENCY IN THE
LAW BY PERMITTING ELECTRONIC
NOTICE FOR ALL REQUIRED NOTICES
FOR TELECOMMUTERS AND STATED
THE NOTICE REQUIREMENT ALREADY
PROVIDE FOR ELECTRONIC.
ALTERNATIVES ONLY BE
COMMISSIONER HAS ALREADY
RECOGNIZED ELECTRONIC NOTICE
BEING SUFFICIENT FOR PREGNANT I
THINK THIS ABILITY LEAVE.
MEDICAL PROVIDER NETWORK
INFORMATION FOR WORKERS COMP
CLAIMS AND SB NINETY FIVE NEW
PAID SICK LEAVE REQUIREMENTS
ELECTRONIC NOTICE MISCIBLE FOR
THESE RIGHTS TO EMPLOYEES IT
SHOULD BE FOR OTHER SIMILAR
RIGHT WELL. AS STATED BY
SHERMAN I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THE INTENT OF THE BILL IS
NOT TO ROONEY THANK YOU
REQUIREMENTS BUT YOU HAVE A
PHYSICAL LOCATION OPEN TO
INFLUENCE THE POSTER
REQUIREMENTS STILL EXIST. BUT
ONLY DRESSES THE ISSUE OF WHEN
YOU HAVE EMPLOYEES WHO DO NOT
FREQUENT THE PHYSICAL WORKPLACE
NO LIFESTYLE WHETHER YOU CAN
SEND THEM. NOTICES AND. FREDDIE
EASILY AT HOME AND THERE'S LESS
RISK OF LOSING AN ELECTRONIC
COPY THAN PHYSICAL ONE THAT
MAIL TO THAT. THE TELECOMMUTING
INCREASES IN TIME FOR THE LAST
UNICORN ONLY ALLOW ELECTRONIC
TRANSMISSION ARE NOTICES AND
POSTERS A PROCESS THAT HAS
ALREADY BEEN APPROVED BY THE
RIVER COMMISSIONER IN MULTIPLE
CIRCUMSTANCES- URGENT IVOTE
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ROOM AND ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
FIFTY SEVEN. LET'S SEE NONE
WILL GO TO YOUR FULL ROOM.
ASCENA WITNESSES ARE WISHING TO
SPEAK WILL COME BACK TO THE
MODERATOR OF THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE- IN ASKING QUEUE UP ANY
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
FIFTY SEVEN. AND PLEASE LET US
KNOW HOW MANY THERE ARE. LA JOH
MAKE YOUR IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK AND
SUPPORT IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME WE DO HAVE THREE IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU. BEN WILL
FIRST START WITH NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWO SEVEN SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I WILL MOVE ON TO NUMER TWO
SIXTY SIX TO SIXTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER TERM
MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
POLICIES FOR TWEENER POSITION
BUT WHILE WE REMAIN AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL AND PRINT. FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED OUR LETTER AND THOSE
DESCRIBED IN THE ANALYSIS- WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
MULTIPLE DISCUSSIONS WE'VE HAD
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND
GIVEN THE AGREEMENT TO AMEND
THE BILL TO ONLY AFFECT POSTING
THE NOTICES. AND ONLY ALLOW
ELECTRONIC DISTRIBUTION IN
ADDITION TO WHAT THE LAW
REQUIRED BY CARP ON REGULATIONS
FOR MODERATOR YOU HAVE TO CUT
OFF THE SPEAKER IN FAIRNESS TO
THE OTHERS SPEAKERS WERE ONLY
ALLOWED TO- WHO ACCEPT THE
NAME. AFFILIATION AND POSITION
I'M SORRY. IN OPPOSITION. THERE
WAS LEGAL. THIS LED LEAD UP
IDENTIFIED THE PRIOR TO
COMMENCEMENT OF THIS MEETING.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. SO. SHE TOLD
OFFICIALS IN. I'M SORRY I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THE RULES- SIR
IF YOU HAD IDENTIFIED AS LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS PRIOR TO
COMMENCEMENT OF THIS MEETING IN
BEGIN IN FAIRNESS EVERYONE ELSE
HAS BEEN PARTICIPATING ALL
AFTERNOON LONG- WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO HEAR YOU- FOUR OF THE
LEASE FOR TWO MINUTES SO FOR
YOUR LIBRATION OF YOUR POSITION
WE CAN'T DO THAT. UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF BECOMING AN
UNDER THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE WHICH IS SO LIMITED TO
NAME AFFILIATION AND-
IMPOSITION SUPPORTER. OPPOSE SO
WE'RE UNDERSTANDING- THE H. YOU
HAVE SOME OF AN UP. THAT
POSITION- AND THEN WE NEED TO
MOVE ON SO I'M IN A MANASSEH
MODERATOR TO MOVE ON- IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE CUTER.
ABSOLUTELY THEN WE'LL MOVE ON
TO NUMBER TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS-
THIS IS RICHARD MARX AND ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION THE PLUMBING
HEATING COOLING CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. SIX FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND WE'LL GO TO NUMBER TWO
FIFTY TWO FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I WILL MOVE
ON TO NUMBER TWO THIRTY THREE
TO THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWO THIRTY THREE OF YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. OKAY AND IF YOU AREN'T
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MR
THANK YOU MMHM AGAIN WE HAVE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
IDENTIFIED BUT WILL ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO.
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. BUT SEE
NO ONE STEPPING FORWARD WILL
MOVE ON TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM.
OTHER NO WITNESSES THERE ARE.
QUEUED UP TO TESTIFY. IN
OPPOSITION WILL MOVE BACK TO
THE MODERATOR OF THIS MODERATOR
ON THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
HE SAID IN A FIGHT ANY
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AND PLEASE LET US
KNOW HOW MANY ARE IN THE QUEUE.
JOHN IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE TO SIXTY VOTES ARE WE HAVE
A THREE IN THE QUEUE CURRENTLY.
THANK YOU. THERE WILL START
WITH- LINE TO SIXTY SIX GO
AHEAD- THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MUCH TIGHTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
APOLOGIES FOR ANY CONFUSION WE
MAY HAVE CAUGHT OUR TESTIMONY
BUT DID JUST WANNA MENTION THAT
WHILE WE DO REMAIN OPPOSED TO
THE BILL IN PLANT. BASED ON THE
COMMITMENT FROM THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE TO AMEND THE BILL AS
DESCRIBED ASSUMING THAT THE
EVENTUAL VERSION IN PRIME DOES-
ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS OF NOT
WEAKENING THE EXISTING POSTING
AND NOTICE REQUIREMENTS THAT
WORKERS. DON'T HAVE YOU KNOW
SOMEONE ADMIRED TO PUNCH THEM
AS REQUIRED UNDER CURRENT LAW
THAT WE- I'M SORRY. RULES IS
RULES AS A SE- WILL MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT THE WITNESS PLEASE.
NEXT WILL BE A NUMBER TWO
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING CHEN MEMBERS CAN
LEARN ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
AND WHAT LINE ARE COMMENTS
WITHOUT CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION THANK YOU. BUT. THE
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER TWO FIFTY
TWO FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TAYLOR JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION WE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION. THEN ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU AND WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE LET ME
JUST ASK YOU POINT FOR ME-
METAL BY SURE. AS YOU OFFER THE
BILL. ON IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING- IN IN PART FROM.
THE TESTIMONY WE ARE SOME OF
THE TESTIMONY HER TODAY BUT
ALSO FROM YOUR PRESENTATION AND
ALSO- FROM WORK THE COMMITTEE
THE STAFF IS DONE THAT THEY
WERE- ARE ONGOING NEGOTIATIONS
TO- TO BRING AMENDMENTS BEFORE
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WHICH
SHOULD BE THE NEXT OFFER THIS
BILL I JUST WANTED TO. ASK YOU
TO CONFIRM THAT ON THE RECORD
IT'S IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE ASKING
THE COMMITTEE. TO DO TO
INSTANCES SUPPORT THIS BILL
WITH ONGOING NEGOTIATIONS ON
AMENDMENTS- TO MOVE TO. TO THE
NEXT COMMITTEE ABSOLUTELY AS A
MATTER OF FACT WE'VE HAD IT I'M
GOING CONVERSATIONS TODAY THIS
MORNING AND- UNFORTUNATELY THE
OPPOSITION OR THE QUESTION OF
THE CONCERNS THAT WERE BROUGHT
UPWERE. LATE LAST WEEK AND SO
WITH THE HOLIDAY WEEKEND IT
JUST MADE IT DIFFICULT TO GET
EVERYTHING AND WRITING FIRE TO
HAND BUT WE DID YOU SEE SOME OF
OUR OF OUR MEN AND LANGUAGE- AS
IT THIS WEEKEND AND WE'RE
CONTINUING TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT THEY HAVE
RIGHT NOW WHICH IS. ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I SPECIFIED IN MY
OPENING REMARKS SOME OF THE
TERMS AND I'M WILLING TO
ADDRESS MOVING FORWARD. IF THE
COMMITTEE ALLOWS ME TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE FAILED BUT IN
REALITY IT BUT IN YES I
UNDERSTAND IT SO. SO IN SHORT-
IN SHORT WOULD YOU BE SICK
TODAY IS- IS A MOTION THE UNDER.
THAT THE MAN OF THE MIDDLE.
CURRENTLY ONGOING. THAT WOULD
BE TAKEN UP IN THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. YES SO JUST GETTING
THE FORMAL LANGUAGE- ON AND I
HAVE NO. I HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
OBJECTIONS TO THE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP AS AN
TODAY. WE THINK THANK YOU-
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CENTER ALERT. IRMA CUT A FINER
POINT ON THE CHAIRS QUESTION.
HAVE THE AMENDMENTS NOT BEEN
AGREED TO YET. THAT WE HAVE SO
THEY WERE THEY WERE TWO SETS
OF- CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE THE
FIRST SET OF CONCERNS THAT WE
CAME OVER. AS OF LAST. FRIDAY I
BELIEVE. HAVE BEEN ADDRESSING
WE AGREED- TO ADD THAT THE
CLARIFICATION LANGUAGE TO THE
BILL. TODAY THERE WERE SOME
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS THAT. NOT
CONCERNS BUT MORE CLARIFICATION
PURPOSES- ON WHAT THEY WANTED
TO MAKE SURE SO. I'LL GIVE AN
EXAMPLE NO. JUST LOOKING FOR
THE PROCESS NOT THE SUBSTANCE
OF HIS RIGHT HAND SO. IT'S
BASICALLY THERE WERE TWO. SETS
OF CONCERNS FIRST ONE
AMENDMENTS AGREED TO HIM THIS
MORNING DID YOU AGREE TO
AMENDMENTS ON THE SECOND YES
THEY'RE JUST NOT IN PRINT YES
AND- SO THERE IS AN AGREEMENT.
ON AMENDMENTS AND- HI
UNFORTUNATELY. THE DIDN'T ALLOW
HIM GET TO THE AND- OF FROM THE
LAW FED WHERE HE WAS TO SAY.
WHATEVER THEIR P. WHILE AND SO
DO YOU BELIEVE THEIR POSITION
AS- THE DOG OF NEUTRAL WITH THE
SECOND SET OF AMENDMENTS THAT
YOU AGREED TO TODAY DO YOU KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE QUITE WHAT THAT
WILL DO TO THEIR STANCE. MISTER
CHAIR WOULD IT BE OKAY TO GET
CLARIFICATIONS FROM THE LEAK
FROM THE WEEK- FROM THE
SPEAKER. THE CENTER ALERT
CENTER. I THINK YOU I THINK IF
IT IS YOUR PREROGATIVE BUT I
THINK IF. YOU AYE AYE AYE IT'S
ROCKETS NOT FAIR TO ASK HER TO
CHARACTERIZE THE OTHER POSITION
FOR THE RECORD IT'S- NO BUT I A
WELL WHAT I WANTED TO SAY IS
IT'S NOT OUT OF ORDER FOR YOU
TO QUESTION. A WITNESSES
UNIVISION WILL KNOW SO I DON'T
KNOW WE CAN AS A MODERATOR IF-
IF THE WITNESS IS STILL
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE TOLL
CONFERENCE SERVICE IN IT I
DON'T KNOW. BUT THAT SERVICE
SITUATION- AVAILABLE FROM
FAMILY PERFECT I WOULD ASK HIM
A QUESTION IF THE MODERATOR CAN
TELL US. MISTER MODERATOR. I
NOT SHOW THAT THERE CURRENTLY
ON THE CALL ANYMORE. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR LET ME SAID. THIS IS.
BY TEMPORARILY THE FLOOR. I AM
A MEMBER OF THE TO DO.
COMMITTEE AS WELL SO ARE. OUR
OUR BELIEF THAT THERE'S BEEN
GOOD FAITH CONVERSATIONS ARE
WILLING TO SUPPORT MOVING
ALONG. BUT OUR WALL. ACT ON
BEHALF OF EVERYBODY HERE TO
REPRESENTED THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE THAT. THAT IT WAS
MOVED ON THE BASIS OF THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE GOING TO BE
WORKED OUT. I DO HAVE AN EMAIL
THAT I COULD. FORWARD T. RIGHT
NOW OUR SHOW YOU I JUST THINK
WE WERE WHERE WE ARE WE'RE GOOD
WITH IT IS NOT WRITING ABOUT IN
THAT POSITION I WOULD AGREE
AMOUNT OF ASSURANCE AND EARLIER
THAT- PROCESS. WE HAVE TO
PROCESS OVER SUBSTANCE RIGHT
NOW WOULD PROBABLY BE. IMPROPER
TO TRY TO TAKE UP WITH
AMENDMENTS ARE AN IMPRINT AT
THIS TIME BUT I DO APPRECIATE-
HONORED REPOSITORY. NO BECAUSE
IF I FELT LIKE THERE WAS AN
AGREEMENT. IN THE AGREEMENT
CHANGED THE STANCE OF THE
OPPOSITION. THE NIGHT GIVE ME
EVEN MORE OF A COMFORT LEVEL
THAN JUST HAVING TO WORK TO
ENFORCE IT IN JUDICIARY. EITHER
WAY. I THINK WE'RE GOOD. I WILL
SAY AS THOSE THOSE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY I HAVE TO WORK
DIRECTLY WITH COMMITTEE STAFF.
THE REPRESENTATIONS RECEIVED
FROM THE OPPOSITION- THROUGH
THIS COMMITTEE. HAVE BEEN THAT
THERE IS AN OFFICIAL VERSION OF
THIS BILL THAT THEY WILL
SUPPORT AND THERE'S ONGOING
NEGOTIATIONS TO GET THAT
LANGUAGE AND DEPRESSED. THAT'S
WHAT WE KNOW. S. AND I BELIEVE-
AS MISTER CHAIR AT THAT THAT
BELIEVE THE MISTER MITCHELL IS
STILL AVAILABLE ONLINE. TWO SIX
SIX. BUT I THINK IT POINT
MISTER. RUBIO WORSE I DON'T
THINK THE MARKET OKAY I DON'T
THINK WAS A MOVIE OUR MORE ALL
THE UNDERSTOOD STEP WE'VE HAD
JUST THIS COME. OUR MOVE THE
BILL BY. THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED AGAIN WITH YOUR THAT THE
ON- NEGOTIATE ON AMENDMENTS-
WILL BE TAKEN UP IN JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE ON THAT'S THAT'S THE
MOTION AS AS I UNDERSTAND IT
STRUCTURE YES YES. SENATOR
NEWMAN I'M SORRY. AND I DO A
PRE CENTER LIZARDS COMMITMENT
TO ACT ON OUR BEHALF I HAVE.
AND I PAUL I AM VERY SENSE AS
TO THE SUBSTANCE OR EVEN THE
CHEST- OF THOSE ISSUES WERE. AT
THAT ARE SUBJECT TO AMENDMENT-
MUCH LESS ONE AT. AT THE
OPPOSITION IS WILLING TO ACCEPT
THEM OR ACCEPT THE AUTHORS
REPRESENTATION AT THE INCIRLIK
TO OTHER MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
OR USE IT GIVING ME THE HANDS
SO. THEN I'M FINE IT TALK ABOUT
HIS BLIND ON THIS BILL AS I'VE
BEEN ON ANYTHING A WHILE I'M
SURE IT'S NOT IT'S. IT'S
PROBABLY NOT MONUMENTAL. WOULD
YOU WANT TO GO HOME NO YOU'RE
NOT BLINDED. I WOULD NOT COP TO
THAT. OKAY WHAT DO SO IT TOO TO
THE AUTHORS SECTION RICH ABOUT
IT IF YOU WOULD NOT. JUST IN
BRIEF. WHAT IS THE GIST OF
THOSE ISSUES WORSE THOSE ITEMS
WERE STE WHICH- STILL ARE IF
YOU. ENTER SUBJECT TO AMENDMENT
DISCUSSION JUST SO I KNOW
BEFORE I CAST A VOTE ABSOLUTELY
SO ONE OF THE CONCERNS OF THE
THAT WAS RAISED TODAY WAS THE
FACT THE OR- THE-
MISUNDERSTANDING THAT. THIS WAS
IN LIEU. THEY THEY WOULD
RECEIVE DENTAL YOU WOULD
RECEIVE ELECTRONIC NOTICES IN
LIEU OF HAVING THEM POSTED IN
IN. I EMPLOYERS OFFER FOR.
PERSONAL SO WE JUST NEED TO ASK
PERFECT LANGUAGE THIS IS NOT
AND WILL OF THIS IS IN THAT. TO
THE POSTINGS OF CURRENT LOSS-
OR CURRENT DISCLOSURES SO- ALL
THIS IS DOING JUST AND SO. THEY
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THAT IN WRITING- WITH THE
INTENT OF THAT RECEIVING THESE-
ELECTRONIC NOTICES. OKAY THAT
AND IT'S THAT'S THE TO IT
BECAUSE THE SEEMS RELATIVELY
TRIVIAL. THIS SERVICE IS THAT
MY COLLEAGUES UNDERSTANDING AS
WELL AS A MEASURE THAT DOESN'T
ASSURING COMPORT WITH THE
ANALYSIS I'VE READ SUCH AS
SENATOR US GOOD. SENATOR PLEASE.
A I THINK SIR LEARN WHO GUN TO
THE GIST OF WHAT WORK WE'RE
TRYING TO DO BUT I DO THINK
THAT THEY WERE VERY SERIOUS
ISSUES AND I WAS NOT PREPARED
TO SUPPORT BASED ON WHAT THE
ORIGINAL OF A PROPOSAL- BILL
WAS- AND I'VE YOU KNOW IT TO
SUBSTITUTE WAS ONE GREAT
SUBSTITUTE LIKE TRONIC FOR A
WORKPLACE WHERE JUSTIN AT TIME
OF. UNCERTAINTY AS TO WHO'S
GOING TO WORK REMOTE WHO'S
GOING TO STAY HOME WITH YOU
KNOW WHO'S GOING TO GO IN
THERE'S ALL THOSE UNCERTAINTIES
SO- YOU KNOW NO RELIABLE ACCESS
TO- CONNECTIVITY EMAIL AND
ITSELF I AM ALSO AT THIS POINT
ARE READY TO SUPPORT BECAUSE OF
THE COMMITMENT THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE ON THESE ISSUES- AND I
ALSO I'M ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE SAID TWO BOATS HERE.
TO ROADS HERE- AND I'M I'M SURE
THE AUTHOR OF WILL ADDRESS THIS
IN SUCH A WAY HOPEFULLY THAT
RESOLVES IT AND THEN WE WILL DO
THE FINAL VOTE SO BANK FINAL
THING OF A CENTER NEWMAN AND I
DO APOLOGIZE SIR SO THE ONE
ISSUE- THAT THAT DON'T HAVE IN
FRONT OF A THEY CAME UP. MY
READING WHAT THE CA. THAT AN
EMPLOYEE MONITORING OF THE
SELECTION COMMUNICATIONS WOULD
BE VISIBLE TO THE EMPLOYER AND
MIGHT SUBJECT THEM TO
RETALIATION AND SO YOU'RE NOT
IN YOUR HEAD YES SIX SENATOR
OSCAR OF MY ONE OF MY CONCERNS
RICHARD SHOWED IT DOWN YOU'RE
NODDING YOUR HEAD NO CENTER
SHOW ABOUT AUTHOR I'M SORRY I'M
NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND YOUR-
CONCERN WHICH WAS RAISED IN THE
ANNOUNCES THAT I READ WAS THAT
AN EMPLOYEE WORKING FROM HOME.
THAT WAS GETTING ELECTRONIC
NOTICES AND THEN ACTING ON THEM
MIGHT BE SUBJECT TO MONITORING
BY THEIR EMPLOYER AND AS A
RESULT MIGHT BE SUBJECT TO
RETALIATION IF THE EMPLOYER
WASN'T HAPPY WITH THE RESULT OF
THOSE INTERACTIONS ARE THE
INTERACTIONS AND FOLLIS. SAID
IS THAT BEEN RAISED IN ANGER
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE OPPOSITE.
SO THEIR WIVES BUT I THINK THEY
WERE A MISS ON. AS TO. THE
INTENT OR- FOR- THE NOTION
THESE ARE THE NOTE THAT DMP
WOULD POSE. IN THERE IN THEIR
PLACE WORK THAT EMPLOYEES WOULD
BE SUBJECT TO YOUR BE ABLE TO
SEE IT WORK AND- IN ADDITION TO
HAVING THEM POSTED. BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC AND HAVING THEM
WORK TELECOMMUTING AND WORKING
REMOTELY. THEY WOULD ALSO BE
ABLE TO OPT IN TO BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE THESE NOTICES VIA EMAIL.
SO THAT'S THAT'S THAT THERE'S
NO SENSE OF INTIMIDATION OR
IT'S JUST IT'S DISCLOSURE-
OPPORTUNITY AN OPTION THAT
EMPLOYEES WILL HAVE SO THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO IN
PERSON. TO THE WORKPLACE- IF
THEY FEEL UNSAFE IN GOING TO DO
SO IT'S JUST CREATING AN
ADDITIONAL. DISCLOSURE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE EMPLOYEES
SO THAT THEY CAN BE SAFELY
WORKING FROM HOME GETTING THE
DISCLOSURES AT HOME AND THEY'RE
NOT EXPOSED TO. POP TO HAZARDS
BASICALLY ON THE OTHER THING
THAT I FAILED TO MENTION
EARLIER YOUR SD THE CONCERN
THAT WE HAVE- OUTLINE THAT I
MENTIONED IN MY IN MY REMARKS
MY OPENING REMARKS. WAS THE-
THE ABILITY TO HAVE A WET
SIGNATURE SO WE'RE ACTUALLY
DELETING NOT- SO THAT THEY WILL
NOT BE PART OF THE BILL THAT
WAS ANOTHER CONCERN THAT THEY
HAVE WHICH WHICH WE'VE AGREED
TO REMOVE IT AND HAVE NO
PROBLEM WITH DOING THAT ALL
WE'RE DOING IS. JUST HOPEFULLY
TO EMPOWER EMPLOYEES TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THE
DISCLOSURE WITHOUT SUCCUMBING
TO ENVIRONMENTAL OR HEALTH
HAZARDS. WHILE WE'RE- LOWER
GOING. TO ALL OF THE SPENDING.
RICHARD DOT NIGHT FREE SHOULD
MY CALL. COMMITMENT ACT MY PRO
MOVES FORWARD. BUT THERE IS A
SINNER NO I'LL GIVE A TO BE A
ONE X. IS YOU GET OPPOSE.
ELECTRON ASSISTING FROM A
POSTER THAT SAYS YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT TO COMPLAIN IF YOU'VE
BEEN SUBJECT TO SAY HARASSMENT.
I AM BUT YOU'RE USING THE
EMPLOYERS VIRTUAL NETWORK. AND
AS A RESULT YOUR IP ADDRESSES
USUALLY TRY SO THAT EMPLOYER
COULD KNOW QUITE WELL WHO IT
WAS WHO WAS ACTING UPON. THAT
INFORMATION YOU WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY BE. ANONYMOUS IN
YOUR PURSUIT OF REDRESS
ORDINARY MEN STARTING THAT
PROCESS. AND SO THAT'S A
CONCERN THAT WAS ACTUALLY REYES
AND ANALYSIS THAT I READ- AND
SO IF YOU'LL GIVE THE ASSURANCE
THAT YOU WORK THROUGH THAT I'M
OKAY WITH IT BUT I DO THINK
THAT'S EIGHT. EIGHT A
SUBSTANTIAL CONCERN WE SHOULD
BE. APPS I AS I SAID THIS IS
ONLY FOR THE PROTECTION OF BOTH
THE EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS THE
EMPLOYERS. AND WE'VE BEEN
HAVING I. BEEN ATTEMPTING TO
ENGAGE WITH EVERYONE IN GOOD
FAITH AND IN GOOD WELL THAT AS
A- FRESHMAN SENATOR I'M TRYING
TO MAKE THIS. AS AS AS EASY.
VERY NON CONTROVERSIAL BILL AS
WE CAN MOVING FORWARD. BUT IF
I'VE LEARNED ANYTHING WITH VERY
FEW BILLS ARE NOT CONTROVERSIAL.
SORRY MISTER CHAIR I WILL GIVE
MY PROVISIONAL A VOTE TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD AND I TRUST IN MY
COLLEAGUES WILL. MONITOR THIS
IS A MOVES FORWARD. WITH THE
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
NEWMAN THIRTY OF- FIVE I DO
THINK DETAILS- UPON DETAILS OR-
THE WHAT THREATEN THE VIABILITY
THE BILL DESPITE THE FACT THEY
LIKE WHAT I HEAR YOU SPEAK INTO
YOUR INTENTIONS ARE NOBLE TERMS
OF TRYING TO. CREATE YOU KNOW
ELECTRONIC OVERLAY IS WHAT I
HEAR FROM BUT TO BOOT WELCOME
TO WILL BE A LOT OF WORK TO DO
I THINK BETWEEN NOW AND GETTING
THAT THE- THROUGH NEXT
COMMITTEE SO THAT SAID WITH
THOSE CALL THE ARTS- WE DO HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR LAYERED
WHICH- IS- YOU KNOW INCLUDED-
UNDERSTAND. AND WE CAN CALL THE
QUESTION NO. INVEST FOR ROLL
CALL VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
SENATOR CORTEZ E. HI
INTERPRETERS THE ICE AND- CHAU
BOKE HI AND- CHAU FOLK HI
SENATOR DORADO. IN ORDER TO
ROUTE SO I SENATOR LAYERED HI
SENATOR LAYERED HI SENATOR
NEWMAN. SENATOR NEWMAN AYE THE
BILL HAS FIVE PLATES TO THE
BILLS OUT. WE THIS. MMHM WE DO
HAVE OF ONE MORE BILL SB THIRTY
THREE WHICH IS MINE BEFORE IT
PASSED THE GAVEL- TO ABOLISH
YOUR TO PRESIDE HELLO PRESENTED
BILL I WOULD AS THE CHAIR LIKE
TO- LOOK THE CALL- AND- W. ONE
BILL WILL RESTORE A CALL. IF
YOU CAN. DO THAT PLEASE. FOR
THE PREVIOUS. SB TWO SEVENTY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY SENATOR LAYERED-
LAYERED HI THE BILL HAS- FOR
VOTES. THE BILL HAS. FOUR YOU
SHOULD BE A TOTAL LOCAL
APPLICATION BILL TO STERN- FOR
AN AND ONE OR IN FOREIGN-
WANTING THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING THAT- THE BILL IS UP.
SO I'M GONNA PASS GAVEL- FOR
THE RECORD SHOWS PASSED THE
GAVEL TO THE VICE CHAIR WHO
WILL NOW PRESIDE IN WOOD
INVITED TO PRESENTED LIKE TO
PRESENT. WELCOME SENATOR
CORTESE YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL AND SB THIRTY THREE. THANK
YOU MA'AM SURE.
PLEASE HERE.
AGAIN THANK YOU- MELCHERS
SOONERS SUB PLEASE RISEN SB
THIRTY THREE SB THIRTY THREE
CREATES THE CONSTRUCTION
APPRENTICESHIP ADVANCEMENT TASK
FORCE TO STUDY THE RECRUITMENT
RETENTION BARRIERS TO ENTRY OF
WOMEN UNDERREPRESENTED AND
DISADVANTAGED POPULATIONS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ENSURING
APPRENTICESHIP OPPORTUNITIES.
ARE MORE INCLUSIVE OF THOSE
POPULATIONS INCREASING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HIGH WHICH
CONSTRUCTION JOBS WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE ECONOMIC
SECURITY FOR ALL COMMUNITIES
UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE GROWING
EFFORTS RUN OUTREACH
RECRUITMENT AND REPORTING
REPRESENTATION DISPARITIES
AMONG WOMEN AND OTHER
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
POPULATIONS IN THE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADE SECTOR
PERSIST TO THIS DAY. SB THIRTY
THREE INCREASES ACCOUNTABILITY
ENSURES THAT APPRENTICESHIP.
OPPORTUNITIES ARE MORE
INCLUSIVE OF WOMEN. AS AS
DISCIPLINE UNDER POPULATIONS
CREATE A BODY OF STAKEHOLDERS
TO FOCUS ON THOSE EFFORTS. I
WANT TO MAKE NOTE THAT I'VE
SUBMITTED ALL TO REMEMBER IT'S
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THESE
AMENDMENTS MAKE THE TASK FORCE
MORE INCLUSIVE AND GIVE
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS. BUT WHICH I
HAVE EXPERIENCE WORKING TO
DIVERSIFY APPRENTICESHIPS OF
VOICE IN THE PROCESS
SPECIFICALLY THOSE AMENDMENTS-
FOR THE TASK FORCE. FOCUSED ON
DIVERSIFYING CONSTRUCTION
APPRENTICESHIPS INTO THIS IN
THE BILL IN PRINT NOW PLIES TO
ALL SECTORS AND OCCUPATIONS
USING A PRESSURE THAT WOULD
INCLUDE IT. MANUFACTURING
HEALTHCARE FOR EXAMPLE.
SECONDLY THE MEMBERS OF THE
LANGUAGE RECORD THE TASK FORCE
TO CONSULT WITH ORGANIZATIONS
WITH EXPERIENCE WORKING TO
DIVERSIFY REPRESENTATION OF
APPRENTICES. THESE AMENDMENTS
EXPLICITLY NAME ORGANIZATIONS
WITH EXPERIENCE IN ROLLING
PLACING WOMEN WERE CURRENTLY
THE MOST UNDER REPRESENTED
GROUP IN CONSTRUCTION INTO
HIGHWAYS CONSTRUCTION CAREERS.
THE WITH TODAY'S SHOW CREWS
WITH THE LABORS INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF NORTH AMERICA. BUT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF ALONG WITH
EMILY COHEN A DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT FOR UNITED
CONTRACTORS ALSO TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT BUT EFFORTS TO INCREASE
WOMEN WORKING IN THE TRADES.
THE MANAGER THE SENATOR FOR.
THANK YOU SENATOR CORTESE WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANYONE AT
TESTIFYING- I'M SORRY FOR NOT
MOVING ON TOWARD LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES WE HAVE JOE CRUZ AND
EMILY COLLINS AND I'LL LET YOU
FOLKS BOTH DECIDE WHICH ONE
WOULD LIKE TO GO FIRST. A
MANAGER THIS IS JOE CRUZ. I'LL
GO AHEAD AND LEAD OFF- JOE
COULD NOT BE HAPPY CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL LABOR SENT WORSE
PROBABLY SUPPORT SPONSORING AT
THREE THIRTY THREE. POINT BANK
OF THE AUTHOR FOR CHAMPIONS
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUE.
LABOUR'S HAVE LONG SUPPORTED BY
ADVERSITY IN THE WORKPLACE AND
TAKE PRIDE IN PUTTING ENTRY.
LEVEL WORKERS ON THE PATH TO
THE MIDDLE CLASS. CONSTRUCTION
USING. WORKING COULD NOT FIND
ENOUGH SKILLED LABOR. FACTORS
CREATING THE SORT IS INCLUDE
DECREASED SUPPORT FOR TECHNICAL
AND VOCATIONAL EDUCATION
TRAINING AND THE FACT THAT MANY
WORKERS ARE LIKELY UNAWARE OF
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EARN IN
MIDDLE CLASS INCOME WORKING IN
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
WITHOUT ACTION. LABOR SHORTAGES
LIKE YOU BECOME WORSE. IT
RETIREMENT WAVE THAT IS
EXPECTING IT INDUSTRY. ROUGHLY
40% OF CONSTRUCTION WORK FORCE
IN CALIFORNIA IS EIGHT FORTY
FIVE OR OLDER. THAT MEANS
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS WILL BE
APPROACHING RETIREMENT. AGE
WITHIN THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
UNFORTUNATELY OTHER. RECRUITING
WOMEN INTO THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA WOMEN
ONLY MAKE UP NINE PERCENT. OF
THE OVERALL CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY AND THAT HAVE TO
CHANGE. THE LABOR SHORTAGE
COMBINED WITH CALIFORNIA'S
CONTINUE NEED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE HOUSING AND
OTHER CONSTRUCTION INVESTMENT
MEANS THAT WE ABSOLUTELY NEED
WOMEN TO JOIN THE INDUSTRY AND
RISE THE RANKS WITHIN THE
CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CAPITAL
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS CAN CREATE
UNPRECEDENTED ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY A CHANCE TO LET THE
INEQUITIES IN INCOME. EARNING
ASSET AND WEALTH. WHY WOULD
STATE THIRTY DEMOGRAPHIC
PROFILE FOR DECADES IT IS
IMPORTANT WE BRING THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY AND STATE
WORKFORCE LEADERS TOGETHER
COULD PASSPORTS CAN DEVELOP
GUIDELINES TO ADDRESS EQUITY IN
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. THE
LABOR THAT RECENTLY EMBARKED ON
A STATEWIDE RECRUITMENT
CAMPAIGN AIMED AT ATTRACTING
WOMEN AND MINORITIES TO WORK IN
A HEAVY CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
COMBINED WITH THE EFFORTS OF
BOTH UNIONS AND CONTRACTORS. WE
NEED A PASSPORT AT THE PIVOTAL
DEVELOPMENT AND BEST PRACTICES
AND PROVIDING OVERSIGHT FOR
MONITORING OUTCOMES AND
REPORTING PROGRESS IN
CHALLENGES TO THE PUBLIC. SB
THIRTY PEOPLE BRIDGE THE
OPPORTUNITY GAP THEY CONNECT
UNEMPLOYED UNDER EMPLOYED
DISADVANTAGED AND THAT'S
AFFECTED IT IN. THE FAMILY
SUPPORTING JOB OPPORTUNITIES
THROUGH THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT ARE SPENT ON
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR THESE REASONS
MANAGER OF THE LABOR OF PROUD
TO SPONSOR AND I'M SHOWING
SUPPORT AT THE THIRTY THREE AND
RESPECT YOUR QUESTION I WROTE.
THANK YOU IS EMILY CALLING ON
THE LINE. YES GOOD EVENING-
EMILY COHEN EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
CONTRACTORS REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA HEAVY ENGINEERING
UNION CONTRACTORS ARE FIVE
HUNDRED PLUS MEMBERS EMPLOYED
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA IN BUILT IN NINETEEN
OUR STATE'S MOST VITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE SERVICE. I'M
CREEK TO IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY THREE. WE ARE PROUD OF
THE FACT THAT THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY HAS TRADITIONALLY BEEN
ONE OF THE STRONGEST AND
LIGHTEST PATHWAYS TO THE MIDDLE
CLASS. UNION CONSTRUCTION
PROVIDE GOOD WAGES HEALTH CARE
PENSION AND MORE. IT REMAINS
THE TRUE SOURCE OF PRIDE THAT
ANYONE WHO IS WILLING TO WORK
HARD TO SUCCEED IN THE UNION
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. UNITED
CONTRACTORS IN THE WE- WEAPONS
THAT RECOGNIZE THE VALUE AND
BENEFITS OF STRIVING FOR A MORE
DIVERSE AND INCLUSIVE INDUSTRY.
THIS YEAR UNITED CONTRACTORS
HOPE TO THE CUSTOMER EXECUTIVE
INDUSTRY ROUND TABLE ON THAT
BURKE THAT THE EQUITY AND
INCLUSION WITH MORE THAN TWENTY
INDUSTRY. PARTICIPATING. AND
WE'RE GEARING UP TO HOST MANY
MORE. EXPLORING UNDERSTANDING
BEST PRACTICES IN THE STATE
WILL HELP ATTRACT MORE TALENT
WHICH IS CRITICAL FOR OUR
INDUSTRY. THE WORK THAT OUR
INDUSTRY DOES CANNOT BE
OUTSOURCED SO IT IS VITAL TO
OUR SUCCESS INTO THE- LAST.
THAT WE CAN ATTRACT RETAIN AND
ALLOCATE MORE DIVERSE WORKFORCE
OUR MEMBERS NOTED AND THE VALUE
THAT. WE WANT CALIFORNIA OF ALL
BACKGROUND WILL BE FOR GREAT
AND REWARD CAREER TO THINK OF
UNION CONSTRUCTION. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR TO DEVELOP A
MORE ROBUST TASK FORCE THAT
WILL CREATE A BROADER
PERSPECTIVE TO HELP DRIVE THE
BEST IDEAS PRACTICES AND
ULTIMATELY OUTCOME. ON BEHALF
OF UNITED CONTRACTORS- WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON SB THIRTY THREE THANK
YOU. FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH WITH THIS
IS HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
SB THIRTY THREE SEEN. NINE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN TWENTY
FORTY TWO IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
TWO WHICH TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTY THREE. SEEING NONE.
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WANTING TO TESTIFY
THE OF THE TELECONFERENCES.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PUMP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
THREE WILL BEGIN. AND LOSE YOUR
MENTOR IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
THREE. THE MODERATOR KING
PLEASE GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT PLEASE. AT THIS TIME-
WE HAVE NOBODY IN OUR QUEUE.
THANK YOU. IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE- THE LEGAL
POLICY. LET'S MOVE ON TO LEAD
OPPOSITION. I HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION ON ON RECORD IS NOT.
THAT IS CORRECT SO WE WILL MOVE
TO. ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION JINAN.
ROOM TWENTY FORTY ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. C. NINE WILL NOW
OPEN THE LINES- TWO WITNESSES
TO TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE. MODERATE YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTY THREE
WILL BEGIN. ANALYSTS JONES HERE
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE
ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE. AT THE TIME
WE HAVE BEEN DONE IN OUR QUEUE.
THANK YOU MODERATOR. THANK YOU
TO ALL OF OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS DURING OUR MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTER NEWMAN SENATOR RUSSIA
OFTEN ADDRESS SOME. THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR I THINK THIS-IS A VERY GOOD- BILL WHICH I
INTEND TO MOVE WHEN I'M-
ALLOWED TO- BUT I ALSO WANT TO
SAY THAT THERE ARE OTHER-
THERE'S OTHER LEGISLATION THAT
I KNOW IS MOVING IN IN THE
DIRECTION THIS IS A REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT. PART OF THAT
AND I HAVE THE TELEPHONE AND
JOBS PLANNED- PROPOSED
LEGISLATION AND IT WOULD. FIT
IN GREAT TO HAVE THESE KINDS OF
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS FOR
UNION JOBS THAT WILL. ACTIVELY
RECRUIT WOMEN AND- WE SHOULD
CONSIDERING THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT CALIFORNIA THROUGH
STATE FUNDING. THROUGH FUTURE
FEDERAL FUNDING- THROUGH LOCAL
FUNDING WE ARE TO BE ABLE TO
GET A LOT MORE OUT OF OUR
PUBLIC CONTRACTS SO THIS IS
REALLY A GOOD. GREAT PIECE OF
THAT NIGHT COMMENDED AND
SUPPORTED. THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN THANK YOU MANAGER. I
WANT TO. ACTUALLY BUILD ON THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES SO
AS- MS COLE AND PUT REAL WORLD
THESE THESE JOBS PROVIDE A
PATHWAY TO THE MIDDLE CLASS FOR
THOSE WHO OTHERWISE WOULD NOT
HAVE THEM- THIS WORK AS SHE
MENTIONED CANNOT BE OUTSOURCED.
AND THIS WORK IS SORELY NEEDED
IN CALIFORNIA AND I'M GLAD TO
SAY THAT BECAUSE OF THE PASSAGE
OF SB ONE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WE ARE DOING THAT WORK AT A
SCALE THAT IS COMMENSURATE WITH
THE NEED- SO I COMMEND YOU ON
THIS BILL- IN ON THE PROJECT
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK IF
AND WHEN THIS IS. AMENDED
SYNDERGAARD CHURCH OF LOVE BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. THE THANK
YOU MUCH FOR THAT- SENTIMENT.
CENTER HE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
THE RECIPROCAL ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU CENTER CORTESE- WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR SB. THIRTY THREE
SEVENTY NINE. SENATE ADDRESS
I'M SORRY AND APOLOGISE. SEVEN
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE
SB THIRTY TWO BY SENATOR TO
RAZA. YES THANK YOU THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT WE REFER TO COMMITTEE
AND APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. UNDER
CORTESE HI SENATOR CORTEZ III
CENTER CHOKE HI- THERE- CHAU
POKE HI SENATOR TORONTO.
SENATOR TORONTO HI SENATOR
LAYERED HI SENATOR LAYERED HI
SENATOR NEWMAN NINE. SENATOR
NEWMAN HI THE BILL HAS FIVE.
PERFECT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
MOTION DOES PASS. CONVENTION
CENTERS AND NOW WE WILL PASS
THE. THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY- IF
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THIS COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US ONE INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. PARTICULARLY
ANYONE WHO FELT LIKE HE DID NOT
HAVE ENOUGH TIME TODAY UNDER
THE CONSTRAINTS OR OR CAME IN
UNDER THE WRONG. OF COMMITTEE
HEARING THAT IT'S NOT TOO LATE
TO SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS IN
WRITING THANK YOU- AND AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
I THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA SO
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON THE
REPUBLICAN PLAN IN RETIREMENT
IS HEREBY ADJOURN.